So, da bin ich wieder, ach ja, ich sehe gerade, ich bin halt sogar relativ früh, normalerweise
bin ich ja erst nach 10 on, 08.07.9 monat, huge subscriptions, langeschön für den sub.
Also, was gucken wir uns denn heute an? Ist irgendwas passiert letzten Tage über, wo ich
noch mal einen Senf zu geben muss, bevor wir uns anfangen Videos anzuschauen? Ich weiß gar nicht,
war noch irgendwas? Lass mal überlegen. Ja, dass die ganzen China Miner ihre Grafikkarten verkaufen,
das habt ihr wahrscheinlich mitbekommen, ne? Die Chinesen, also die chinesischen,
China-Chinesen haben ja Krypto-Mining verboten und jetzt verkaufen alle Chinesen ihre Grafikkarten.
Aber es wird uns nichts bringen, weil die verkaufen das alle auf so einem chinesischen eBay,
wo du die Sachen selbst abholen musst und sowas oder in China wohnen und das ist halt für uns
recht uninteressant. Ach ja, und was ich auch witzig fand, ist diese News hier. Warte mal,
die muss ich euch gerade mal zeigen. Es hat auch letztens einer im Stream schon gepostet,
aber jetzt kam das Behalse auch. Ups, warum geht das jetzt nicht? Warte mal. Hat wieder
irgendeine E-Mail-Anhänge geöffnet bei einer Stadtverwaltung. Also ich könnte wetten,
es hat wieder irgendeine E-Mail-Anhänge geöffnet. Ich frag mich immer, vor allem diese Bilder dabei,
WTF, Alter. Ja, hab ich vor ein paar Tagen gelesen, also da weiß ich auch nicht,
was die immer machen. Aber gut, ich mein, wenn man nur Faxgeräte gewohnt ist,
kann sowas ja schon mal passieren. Ja, ihr wisst ja, dass eigentlich bis 2020 Deutschland
führend ist im Bereich von digitalen Ämtern und digitalen Behörden. Wusstet ihr das eigentlich
schon, dass wir da führend sind? Also führend bedeutet jetzt aktuell gesehen, dass man die
Sachen per Fax schickt, aber laut eigener Aussage unserer Chefs sind wir führend in dem Bereich.
Ja, guck da, da hat er es gesagt. Bis 2021 ist Deutschland komplett digital, hat er 2017
erzählt. Also mal ernsthaft, wer hätte das nicht geglaubt? Also ich war komplett felsenfest davon
überzeugt, das wird so kommen 2017. Genauso wie wir auch bis 2018 50 Mbit für alle Haushalte
haben, hätte ich auch nie daran gezweifelt, dass das passieren würde. Also es war mir klar,
dass das es wird alles eintreten. Ist dumm geschwätzt immer. Aber ansonsten ist die Woche
glaube ich nicht allzu viel spannendes passiert. Ja, das stimmt voll, das stimmt voll. Was halt
witzig ist, gerade jetzt zu Corona Zeiten wäre das echt praktisch gewesen, wenn die ganzen
Ämter digital ein bisschen besser aufgestellt wären und sich nicht irgendwelche Daten per
Fax, per Fax checken müssen. Ihr müsst euch das mal überlegen. Fax, Alter, Fax, das ist so alt,
also die, oh warte, ich muss die Musik einen kleinen Tick klar sagen. Fax, das ist so alt,
ich hab noch nicht mal mehr einen Fax, also ich hab noch nicht mal die Möglichkeit, Faxe zu
empfangen bei mir. Ich hab theoretisch einen Multifunktionsdrucker, der glaube ich,
ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, einen Anschluss hat für einen Fax, aber ich wüsste gar nicht,
wo ich das reinstecken soll. Da müsste ich den Drucker irgendwie an die Fritzbox anschließen
oder so. Wozu? Ich will überhaupt keine Faxe empfangen. Ja, das ist alles gelabert,
sieht man ja jetzt auch immer schön. Es wird viel gelabert. Ihr wisst ja auch das. Moment,
Moment, Leit, Moment, Deutschland, Spiele, Leitmarkt, soll das hier, ja, also Deutschland
soll ja auch Leitmarkt für Computerspiele, also nicht wie Leiden, sondern wie Anführen,
Leitmarkt soll Deutschland werden, was Computerspiele angeht. Ich weiß nicht,
in welcher Fantasiewelt man sich da bewegt. Ja, aber es soll so sein, ja.
Das stimmt nicht. Du kannst mittlerweile auch digital Sachen unterschreiben und das zählt.
Sonst müsste ich ja jegliche NDA oder sonst was müsste ich per Fax an irgendeinen Hersteller
schicken oder so. Du kannst das mittlerweile auch schon digital unterschreiben, das funktioniert.
Telefonanschluss. Ja, theoretisch bräuchte, also du brauchst eine Telefonnummer, du brauchst
eine Telefonnummer. Es geht aber auch über VoIP, wenn das der Anbieter richtig macht.
Also wenn der Anbieter, Telekom und Vodafone, die haben ja nur Voice-Over-IP, die haben ja
auch gar kein richtiges Telefon mehr. Ich glaube, die Telekom bietet dir immer noch,
wenn du nur einen analogen Anschluss haben willst, machen die das immer noch. Aber spätestens ab dem
nächsten Telekom, krass, ist es VoIP intern. Ja, das funktioniert, aber wozu Fax? Fax ist
halt echt Pains-Champ. Gut, wenn du keine Telefonnummer hast, dann ist das natürlich mit Fax nichts.
Um nochmal den Rap-God aus meinem Arbeitsamtkurs von damals zu zitieren, machst du Faxen,
mache ich dich mit Achsen. Dann kriegt das Wort Fax mal ganz neue Bedeutung.
Welches deiner Repos ist eigentlich der Preis-Champ? Der Preis-Champ ist nirgendswo auf GitHub. Den
gibt's nicht. Der Preis-Champ ist closed source, Leute. Dass ich das maximal monetarisieren kann,
nur dass ich überhaupt kein Geld dafür bezahle. Kein Geld dafür bekomme. Bezahlen tue ich dafür,
aber ich bekomme kein Geld dafür. Ja, das mit der Trans 3070 unter 80,
das ist das Problem, dass der Crawler die Shops unterstützen muss und da haben die
immer Probleme, deutsche Shops zu unterstützen. Vielleicht gibt es das auch mittlerweile.
Was ich auch lustig finde, dass sie gerade den deutschen Computerspielepreis hervorheben,
das finde ich immer wieder lächerlich. Der deutsche Computerspielepreis ist eines der
unwichtigsten, unbedeutendsten und peinlichsten Veranstaltungen, die wir so zu bieten haben.
Es ist an heißer Luft kaum noch zu überbieten. Ich habe mich an letztes Jahr auch schon mal
darüber ausgelassen, aber wisst ihr, was bestes Multiplayer-Game ist laut dem deutschen
Computerspielepreis? Das beste Multiplayer-Game laut dem deutschen Computerspielepreis ist
eine Nintendo Game, was den Fortschritt verliert, wenn jemand online aus der Session droppt.
Es ist wie um alles in der Welt kann Animal Crossing bestes Online-Game sein. Dann hätten
sie ja meinetwegen lieber Warzone oder irgendetwas ernstzunehmendes Online-Game, was 2020 rauskam,
nehmen sollen. Zu Zeiten als Crysis da was bekommen hat, war das in Ordnung, da hatten
wir auch was. Was gibt es aktuell für Games aus Deutschland? Anno war mal aus Deutschland,
ich weiß nicht, ob Anno noch aus Deutschland ist. Crytek gibt es immer noch, die machen
aber gerade ja nur Dings hier, dieses Wild West Ding, Hunt Showdown oder so. Ansonsten
wüsste ich nicht, was Crytek Moba aus dem ist nie was geworden. Ansonsten was gibt es
denn noch für größere deutsche Studios? Wir haben dazu nicht mal einen deutschen Artikel
auf Wikipedia und der internationale Artikel über die Video-Games-Industrie in Deutschland
ist schon ziemlich... Es stimmt, die Gothic-Leute haben wir noch, aber da weiß ich nicht, ob
sie überhaupt noch gibt. Ach doch, die haben LX gemacht letztens. Ich weiß aber nicht,
ob die noch in Deutschland am Start sind. Ok, Games Publisher, Games Developer of Germany,
ok, wen haben wir da? Ubisoft Blue Bay, das sind die Siedler-Leute, genau, Ubisoft Berlin,
ok, ich wusste nicht, dass sie mit an Far Cry machen. Crysis, das wussten wir. Ach hier,
die Adventure-Stells-Kram, genau. Sagt mir jetzt gerade nichts, aber das ist auch eher
nicht so meine Lords of the Fallen, war das nicht so ein Dark Souls-Klon? Ja doch, ich
erinnere mich wieder. Stimmt, die gibt es auch noch, die habe ich jetzt verwechselt.
Die gibt es auch noch, die hatten aber glaube ich nie bisher so den Riesenhit. Die Gothic-Leute
gibt es, genau, die gibt es immer noch. Stimmt, die gibt es auch noch, die habe ich jetzt
gar nicht. Was haben die in letzter Zeit so gemacht? Nix. Ok, also es hält sich durchaus
in Grenzen. Das war gar nicht so schlecht, das habe ich auch nicht gesagt. Kann mich
nur dran erinnern, dass das der Dark Souls, man kann es ja nicht Dark Souls, na doch, man
kann es so ein bisschen Dark Souls-Klon nennen. Also das sehr stark Dark Souls inspirierte
Game. Das ist auch so eine Redewendung, die mich ja immer nervt. Sobald ein Spiel nicht
easy as fuck ist, ist es sofort Dark Souls. Keine Ahnung, irgendeiner baut einen Jump
and Run, was nicht easy as fuck ist. Und dann kommen dann die ersten an, das Dark Souls
der Jump and Runs. Da kriege ich ja auch immer richtig Cringe-Anfälle. Das ist so ausgelutscht,
diese Redewendung mittlerweile. Die ist glaube ich so ausgelutscht, dass sie noch nicht mal
Computerbild-Spiele. Gibt es überhaupt noch Computerbild-Spiele verwendet? Oh, gibt es
ja noch Computerbild-Spiele. Tatsächlich, nee, gibt es die noch? Jetzt lesen immer noch
eine Million Leute. Okay, ja, Computerbild-Spiele gibt es noch. Was, ich muss jetzt gerade noch
was anderes gucken. Twitch. Ich muss mal kurz gucken, was auf Twitch gerade angesagt ist.
Spielen die Leute noch Souls-Games? Aber warum sieht denn die Twitch-Seite so komisch aus
auf einmal? Kann ich mir nicht einfach anzeigen lassen, was die meisten gesehene Spiele sind?
War das nicht sonst immer auf der Startseite, sodass man einfach die meist gesehene Spiele
hat? Ah, hier. LOL ist wieder vorne GTA. Warum ist denn Valorant auf einmal so weit oben?
Läuft da gerade irgendwas? Ah, da läuft irgendeine E-Sport-Stells hier. Koreanisches E-Sport-Stells.
Okay, weil ansonsten ist Valorant zwar gut dabei, aber nicht ganz vorne mit dabei. Apex
normalerweise auch nicht ganz ganz oben. Okay, da ist ein Stream allein schon mit 22k, alles
klar. Die Fortnite immer noch dabei. Was ich immer erstaunlich finde, dass ich, obwohl
die Leute immer sagen wollten, World of Warcraft übelst Dead, Dead und Rip, Woe und so, das
scheint immer noch ganz gut zu laufen. Gut, ich meine, irgendwo muss Blizzard ja auch Geld
verdienen und Woe ist halt gerade mit Abo-Modell so eine schöne Einnahmequelle, wo man weiß,
das fällt nicht von heute auf morgen weg. Der Scam Train ist am Start. Sorry, danke
Leute für die ganzen Subs. Ich muss mal kurz nachgucken, wer jetzt eigentlich alles am
Start ist. Game Up, Dankeschön für den Prime-Sub. 14 Monate, das ist ja schon Massive Hyper-Subscription
hier. Der Eichler ist am Start, 23 Monate schon. Dann haben wir Slim Beats ist am Start und
der Max, den hatten wir schon. Nice Leute, dass ihr alle wieder da seid und natürlich
für den Point, dass ihr beim Scam Train mitmacht. Schön, dass euch Twitch gebaitet hat, wieder
eure Prime-Sub auszugeben. 18 Anzeige ist raus, Chain-Lore. Dis-Abo. Nee, Woe ist Monats-Abo,
das ist nicht eine kleine Usergruppe. Woe hat ziemlich viele Spieler immer noch. Ich
meine, ich veröffentliche keine Spielerzahlen mehr, aber du kannst davon ausgehen, das ist
jetzt nicht innerhalb von ein paar Jahren von 9 Millionen auf 5000 gedroppt oder so.
Also, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie viele Spieler Woe noch hat, aber es ist bestimmt ordentlich
und selbst wenn man mal ganz, ganz klein stapelt und sagen, keine Ahnung, die haben nur noch
500.000 Spieler, was wahrscheinlich viel zu wenig ist, die haben bestimmt noch deutlich
mehr und allein schon das gibt ja 5 Millionen im Monat, wenn die nur 10 Euro bezahlen und
es sind wahrscheinlich deutlich, deutlich mehr. Woe ist schon ordentlich. Was mich bei
Woe, ich habe es nie richtig großartig gespielt, muss ich sagen, ich habe andere MMOs zwar
durchgesuchtet, aber Woe habe ich nie so richtig reingefunden. Natürlich habe ich ein bisschen
gespielt, aber nie wirklich großartig. Was mich an Woe so vom Beobachten ein bisschen
nervt, ist, dass die wirklich versuchen, alles Mögliche zu monetarisieren. Also, die haben
ja wirklich alles monetarisiert, was geht und das finde ich übrigens nicht gut, weil
ich bin der Meinung, gerade Spiele, ich propagiere ja selbst immer, ich sage, für MMOs ist eigentlich
das beste Modell monatlicher Subscription oder meinetwegen Pay to Play, also man kauft
ein Spiel, man kauft ein Addon und kann ja so viel spielen, aber ich sage immer, Monthly
Subscription, Monthly Fee ist so das beste für MMOs, allerdings nicht, wenn du dann
alles andere auch noch dazu machst. Was Addons? Natürlich sind Addons von Blizzard. Ich meine
nicht, ich meine jetzt nicht irgendwelche UI Addons, ich meine sowas wie, keine Ahnung,
was war das letzte Woe Addon, was rausgekommen ist? Shadowlands. Das musst du immer noch
kaufen oder? Da reicht keine monatliche Gebühr. Du bezahlst Monatgebühr, du musst Addons
kaufen und dann hast du noch ein Microtransaction Store. Also die monetarisieren wirklich alles,
was irgendwie geht. Das finde ich auch leicht leicht übertrieben bei Blizzard, zumindest
bei WoW. Fazit zu Nextcloud 22, ja es hat sich in einigen Bereichen verbessert, die
Apps sind immer noch ziemlich basic und ich werde wahrscheinlich kein großer Nextcloud
Fan werden. Genau, genau, die Kombination verstehe ich, das war ja eigentlich früher
auch normal. Du hattest den MMO, das hat monatlich gekostet, ok, da kannst du sagen, ja die monatlichen
Kosten ist halt super für den Entwickler, der kann seine Leute bezahlen, der kann seinen
Support bezahlen, der kann seine Admins bezahlen, seine Entwickler bezahlen, Serverkosten bezahlen
und das Spiel quasi pflegen, erweitern, sonst wie. Und dann setzt man sich halt auch nebenbei
noch ran mit einem eigenen Team und macht eine Expansion, die man verkauft, wie ein
extra Game. Das verstehe ich, das finde ich auch in Ordnung, was ich aber auch richtig
assi finde, ist, dass du dann noch anfängst mit irgendwelchen Microtransactions. Levelboost
übrigens, das in Kombination, das ist ein absolutes Unding. Plan ist heute, wir gucken,
was wir immer sonntags morgens machen, ich schwätze ein bisschen, wir gucken Videos dabei,
das ist ein absolutes Unding. Gerade Levelboosts, also wenn man ein Pay2play mit Subscription-Modell
hat, dann musst du, aus meiner Sicht ist das Spiel sonst nicht spielenswert, dann musst
du sicherstellen, dass das Spiel so designt ist und so optimiert ist, dass es darauf ausgelegt
ist, dass du ohne zusätzliche Hilfe die Dinger in-Game erreichen kannst mit dem nötigen
Einsatz-Zeitaufwand, wie die Spiele-Designer sich das gedacht haben. Das heißt, wenn man
sagt, okay, jeder der die Monatsgebühr bezahlt, sollte in-Game die gleichen Möglichkeiten
haben und die gleichen Chancen haben und nicht noch zusätzlich durch Microtransactions
den ganzen Kram boosten lassen, weil sonst stellst du das ganze Modell irgendwie, ich
weiß, es ist ja offensichtlich, dass es funktioniert, also sonst stellt sich aus meiner Sicht die
Frage, warum überhaupt? Das finde ich halt kacke. Und gerade bei WoW Classic, wo ja so
die Oldschool Experience im Vordergrund stehen soll, mit Leveln und Social Aspekt ist es
jetzt natürlich noch doppelt bescheuert, ein Levelboost zu machen. Also ich kann nicht
von World of Warcraft reden, ich kann bloß zum Beispiel von Dark Age of Camelot reden,
was ich hier über 10 Jahre gespielt habe. Die GMs, die wurden beschissen bezahlt, das
weiß man mittlerweile, die wurden beschissen bezahlt, der Europa Publisher war ein richtig
großer Kacklan, aber die GMs haben sich abends von daheim oder nachts von daheim teilweise
eingeloggt und ich weiß nicht, ob die das jemals bezahlt bekommen haben, hoffe ich mal
zumindest, eingeloggt, um Leute aus einem verbacken Dungeon rauszuteleportieren und
sowas. Zumindest da kann ich sagen, es gibt schon GMs mit Leib und Seele, die wirklich
zum umfallen Game Mastern sind. 27 Monate, Huge Subscription hier, IQ++++++ für den
Chat. Der Scamtrain ist auf Level 2, Leute, wir haben noch eine Minute Zeit den Scamtrain
voll zu machen. Wenn der Scamtrain voll ist, dann fangen wir auch an Videos zu gucken und
ich laber euch nicht weiter voll, wobei vielleicht sind die Leute auch gerade da, man weiß nicht.
Ja, finde ich nicht gut. Auch als Spieler finde ich den Story in Game nicht, was? Den
Store meinst du wahrscheinlich, ne? Du hast dir das Problem ja schon selbst beantwortet.
Das ist eines der Probleme, die dadurch auftreten. Ja gut, dass es Mounts, Pets und Kosmetik-Shit
gibt, finde ich auch schlimm, weil Character, man muss mal überlegen, was so ein MMO mit
ausmacht. Character Customization ist eines der zentralen, oder, oder, so, Character Upgrade
und Customization ist eines der zentralen Punkte eines MMOs. Wenn ich mir das kaufen
kann, stelle ich quasi in Frage, warum mache ich den Content überhaupt? Warum soll ich
den Content machen, wenn ich mir das Mountain im Shop kaufen kann? Warum soll ich einen
halben Monat grinden für einen One-Time-Event-Mount, wenn ich mir das Mountain ein halbes Jahr später
auch für 5 Euro oder, na gut, es sind Blizzard-Preise, für 20 Euro im Shop kaufen kann? Das ist
lächerlich. Der Kram, der muss, wenn das Monthly-Fee ist und wenn das Pay-to-Play ist,
dann muss das mit dem gleichen Ingame-Aufwand für alle Leute verbunden sein, ohne Abkürzung
durch den Shop. Und wenn ich eben nur 37-jähriger Boomer bin, der arbeiten gehen muss, Familie
hat und nur eine Stunde am Tag oder, keine Ahnung, nur mal 4 Stunden am Wochenende spielen
kann, dann muss ich halt damit leben, dass ich nicht in High-End-Tierrüstung in der
Hauptstadt rumposen kann. Dann habe ich halt Pech. Dann können halt, keine Ahnung, 20-jährige
Harzer, die den ganzen Tag 24-7 grinden, haben dann halt In-Game-Mehr. So ist es halt. Aber
so muss das auch sein. So, das ist meine Meinung dazu. Bounty 20, danke schön für den Prime-Sub.
Übrigens, bei Blizzard, die haben ja noch deutlich mehr verkackt. Könnt ihr euch noch,
wie gesagt, ich bin bei World of Warcraft nur so stiller an der Seitenlinie, Verfolger,
könnt ihr euch noch an dieses World of Warcraft-Turnier erinnern, wo die Community technisch Geld
gesammelt haben und haben gesagt, hey, wir machen jetzt einen Shop für, keine Ahnung,
Mounts, sonst wie was und ein Teil davon geht an so einen Community oder BlizzCon war das
sogar, so ein BlizzCon PvP-Turnier und dass wir quasi die Turnierpreise erhöhen können.
Kann sich da noch jemand dran erinnern? Und wo alle davon ausgegangen sind, ja, okay,
man supportet quasi jetzt mit Shopkäufen das nächste BlizzCon PvP-Turnier, aber Blizzard
bezahlt auch noch ihre normales Preisgeld. So, die Leute haben wie verrückt im Shop eingekauft,
ich hoffe, ich gebe das jetzt halbwegs korrekt wieder, das ist schon ein paar Jahre her,
und dann hat Blizzard gesagt zur BlizzCon, ach ja gut, wir haben ja jetzt so viel Geld
eingesammelt durch die Shop-Verkäufe, wir geben kein normales Preisgeld mehr, muss ich
das mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen. Ein PvP-Turnier von ihrem Game auf ihrer hauseigenen
Messe bekommt kein Preisgeld von Blizzard selbst für die Gewinner. Was ist denn das
für lächerliche Aktion? Und das, ja. Willst du den Chat verkaufen? Warum nicht? Der Chat
ist so high IQ, da könnte man eigentlich mal zu Geld machen. Was macht der 3D-Drucker
mit? Der ist aus. Ja, das ist ja noch schlimmer. Das ist ja noch dümmer. Dass du exklusive
Paywall-Geschichten hast, das ist ja noch schlimmer. Wenn ich Monthly-Fee bezahle plus Pay-to-Play-Add-on,
dann sollte ich eben auch Zugriff haben durch Spielen auf alles, was das Game zu bieten
hat. Ja, richtig. Die sind selber daran schuld, dass WoW auf dem absteigenden Ast ist. Man
kann davon abgehen und wenn jetzt jemand sagt, World of Warcraft ist nicht auf dem absteigenden
Ast, das kann man ja sehen, wie man will, aber allein schon der Fakt, dass Blizzard
vor ein paar Jahren aufgehört hat, Spielerzahlen zu veröffentlichen. Also immer, immer, wenn
ein Unternehmen, das vorher Spielerzahlen veröffentlicht hat, auf einmal aus irgendwelchen
fadenscheinlichen Gründen sagt, sie veröffentlichen keine Spielerzahlen mehr, da hat das immer
damit was zu tun, dass die Zahlen nicht so geil aussehen, wie man das gerne hätte oder
wie man da irgendwelchen Investoren Dollarzeichen in die Augen bringen kann. Immer. Das heißt,
du kannst davon ausgehen, sobald irgendjemand Zahlen veröffentlicht, die immer nach oben
gehen und sich feiert und auf einmal sagt er, ich veröffentliche keine Zahlen mehr,
dann kannst du so sicher wie das Arme in der Kirche davon ausgehen, dass die Zahlen aktuell
nicht mehr stonksen, sondern noch stonk sind. Dota kenne ich mich nicht aus. Aber Dota hat
auch keine monatliche Gebühr. Ja hat der Chat doch. Also ich bin mir sicher, der Chat
war sicherlich maßgeblich am Amazon Basic Corona Impfstoff beteiligt. Es ist noch nicht,
es kommt demnächst. Kennst du dich mit Frauen aus? Ja, wir sind ja bekannt dafür, dass also
gerade der Chat, so hier der Chat aus 24 sieben Hacker-Man Informatiker Leuten, das ist natürlich
bekannt für, dass wir hier Next Level Dating Tipps immer raushauen. Wo ist denn der Sebaro,
der kennt sich aus? Den brauchen wir jetzt. Schaust du eigentlich Serien oder so, wenn
ja, was? Ja, ja, äh, lass mal überlegen, was habe ich zuletzt geguckt? Ähm, fuck,
also nicht so oft, aber was habe ich zuletzt geguckt? Ich muss mich immer wieder an Mr.
Robot erinnern, wo ich die erste halbe Staffel mega geil fand und danach kacke. Upload, Upload
habe ich geguckt, ja, fand ich eigentlich ganz cool, auch wenn es am Ende die letzten
paar Folgen wieder nachgelassen hat. Ich überlege gerade, was war denn das letzte an Serie,
was ich geguckt habe, also das letzte neue. Ich gucke mal kurz, ich gucke mal kurz Amazon,
Zack, Zack, Amazon, your orders. Moment, Moment, Watch. Amazon Prime Video. Bist du dir die
zweite Witcher Staffel anschauen? Wahrscheinlich, auch wenn ich die erste Witcher Staffel nur
okay fand. Okay, aha, hier, also Serious, Originals, Alter, warum ist eigentlich die
Amazon Video App mittlerweile so unübersichtlich? Wo zum Teufel sind Originals? Warum kann man
da nicht mal nach Serien filmen? Das ging doch immer. Verwirrend. Was machen die denn
mit der App? Was ich immer mal wieder gucke, ein paar Folgen, ist Dr. House, aber das ist
ja nicht wirklich neu. Ich kann es euch nicht sagen, weil die Amazon Video App ist einfach
kacke. Heck wait. Ja, doch nicht. Dann nicht. So, fangen wir mal an. Gucken wir mal ein
paar YouTube Videos. Ja, also das Amazon. Wisst ihr, was ich auch richtig Müll finde?
Amazon. Wie heißt das Music Web Player? Ich muss ja mal einen Screenshot von raussuchen.
Gibt es da einen schönen Screenshot von? Ja. Nee, nicht wirklich. Die haben es eher
doch hier. Also, die haben es geschafft bei Amazon. Nee, das ist nicht das Neue. Das ist
irgendeine Mac-Geschichte. Zumindest, die haben es ernsthaft geschafft, dass man, man kann
hier unten normalerweise die Lautstärke regeln bei Amazon Video und die haben es ernsthaft
geschafft, einen Musik Player zu machen, wo man die Lautstärke nicht richtig regeln
kann. Das ist bescheuert. Normalerweise ist noch jemand ein Knopf, um die Lautstärke
zu regeln. Egal, wer es kennt, kennt das UI. Die haben wirklich geschafft, einen Player
zu machen, wo man die Lautstärke nicht richtig regeln kann. Es hat zwar einen Knopf, um die
Lautstärke zu regeln, aber du kannst die Lautstärke nicht in Prozent korrekt regeln. Du kannst
sie immer nur so in 10, in 10 Prozent Schritten regeln. Das heißt, die Musik ist entweder
zu laut oder zu leise. Ich weiß nicht, ob da irgendeiner bei Amazon da gesessen hat,
hat sich gedacht. Ach nee, ach nee. Also, das ist ja, das ist ja User nicht zuzumuten.
Die User sind bestimmt zu dumm, die Lautstärke richtig einzustellen. Den müssen wir das abnehmen
und machen die Lautstärke jetzt nur noch in 10er Schritten. Dann hast du das Problem,
dass du deine Playlist nicht mehr richtig sortieren kannst. Also geht schon, aber ist
eklig im Vergleich zu früher. Also es ist keine Ahnung. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was die
ganzen UI Designer eigentlich machen, alle. Leuchtet mir nicht ein. Chinesische Miner
verkaufen Grafikkarten zu Sportpreisen habe ich ja gerade gesagt. Das ist zurzeit. Wenn
man in China wohnt, ist es eine super Gelegenheit, eine Grafikkarte zu bekommen. Ja, das Netflix
so alles besser, aber ich macht es immer so. Ich habe halt Prime und ich habe mal diese
Prime Video Geschichte mal dazu geholt. Netflix gucke ich mir immer nur. Netflix mache ich
mir immer in den Test, aber wenn ich mal was gucken will, die die Witcher Serie habe ich
auch im Test aber geguckt. Wenn ich das nächste Mal wieder was auf Netflix gucken will, mache
ich mir einfach nur wieder den Test aber überhaupt kein Problem funktioniert.
Ja, das stimmt. Wobei das vom Konzept her gar nicht mal so weit an der Realität vorbeigeht,
wenn man sich ein bisschen weiter denkt in ein paar Jahren. Natürlich das, was ich da
drin gezeigt habe, war natürlich eher nicht realistisch. Alexa kann auch nur in Zehner
schritten. Ja, da haben die sich gedacht, wenn Alexa das nur in Zehner schritten kann, dann
brauche ich brauche ich das in einem Web Player mit Maus und Tastatur Bedienung auch. Wie,
es gibt keine Test Abos mehr? Kann doch nicht sein. Wie gesagt, letzte Witcher Serie habe
ich im Test aber geguckt. Es gibt keine Test Abos mehr. Was soll das? Anzeige ist raus.
Es gibt keine Tests, das ist aber kacke. Ansonsten bezahle ich es einen Monat, ja. Also wie gesagt,
die letzte Witcher Serie habe ich über den Test aber geguckt. Wie machst du das mit der
Telefonnummer? Ja, tja. Wird nicht verraten. Also kennst du die Programmiersprache Open
Edge Abel? Open Edge Abel, ne, kenne ich nicht. Oh, zeige ich mal her. Hat da einer schlecht
geschlafen und von Pascal geträumt oder was? Was gibt das, wenn es fertig ist? Damit machst
du Big Stonks? Ich weiß ja nicht. Und warum sollte man das verwenden? Ne, kenne ich nicht.
Ich wüsste auch nicht, wofür das. Stonks, keine Ahnung. Ja, so kann ich das vorstellen.
Ja, feelsBatman. So, schauen wir uns mal an. Was gucken wir uns denn auf YouTube jetzt an?
Komm, wir lassen uns als erstes mal wieder von Levelcap gebaden. Das muss jetzt sein.
Der wöchentliche Levelcap gebate. Ja, das habe ich mitbekommen. Das mit den Cheats habe
ich mitbekommen, da wollte ich auch ein Video drüber machen. Ja. Das ist ein Video, das
ist ein Video. Das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee und ich wundere mich, dass das nicht früher
schon jemand gemacht hat. Der Vorteil davon ist, also falls es jetzt zu schnell war, ich
erkläre nochmal kurz, wie das funktioniert. Also, du greifst den Video-Output mit irgendeiner
Capture Card ab, dann hast du auf deinem PC eine Software, die das ganze Bild analysiert,
wo sind Gegner und daraus errechnet ist Controller-Bewegung und den Controller-Input schickst du dann
wieder an die Konsole. Also, es ist für die Konsole nicht sichtbar, dass du, dass das
nicht du bist, sondern irgendwie eine Software gesteuert ist. Das ist eigentlich ziemlich
big brain, die Idee, ist jetzt aber auch jetzt nichts bahnbrechend neues, deswegen wundert
es mich, dass man noch nicht auf die Idee gekommen ist, vorher das zu machen. Und das
coole daran ist, dass du theoretisch das erweitern kannst auf jedes Spiel. Du musst halt nur
die passende AI anbieten dafür oder trainieren. Also, nur in Anführungsstrichen. Also, einfach
ist das nicht. Aber du kannst das theoretisch erweitern für jedes Spiel. Das heißt, du
kannst Cheats basteln für Call of Duty, für GTA, für alles mögliche. Und das alles mit
der gleichen Software. Moin. Also, das ist schon wirklich next level big brain, der Kram.
Ohne Scheiß. Zumindest, es ist nicht zu erkennen für die Konsole, weil es läuft ja nix. Also,
es ist weder 5, also ne. Wenn du, normalerweise hast du zwei Möglichkeiten, Cheats zu erkennen.
Es ist weder, du erkennst, dass der, also du erkennst den Cheat direkt, dass der läuft.
Sagen wir mal, du cheats den Battlefield oder Counter Strike oder sonst wie und Steam guckt
im Hintergrund, läuft irgendwie ein Programm, läuft Programm mit spezieller Signatur, was
auch immer. Das heißt, du weißt direkt nach dem Spieler, dass der den Cheat gerade ausführt.
Oder, dass irgendwas auf sich in dein Game rein gehuckt hat oder was auch immer. Also,
sprich, du weißt den Cheat direkt nach, das ist natürlich die beste Variante. Da kannst
nämlich direkt sagen, easy life, ban. So, die nächste Variante ist, bei solchen Cheats,
die sind ja nicht zu erkennen. Also, du kannst ja solche Cheats auf der Konsole nicht erkennen,
weil auf der Konsole selbst nichts läuft, was irgendwie Anhaltspunkte bieten wird, dass
gecheatet wird. Also, die Konsole, die gibt das Bild aus und bekommt Controller Input.
Die Konsole bekommt absolut gar nichts, gar nichts mit davon. So, was du jetzt aber machen
kannst, du kannst das Ganze natürlich indirekt nachweisen. Zum Beispiel über Statistik.
Wie schnell ist der Typ on target? Wie genau ist er on target? Was ist seine Hitrate im
Vergleich zu den besten Spielern der Welt? Kannst du verschiedene Sachen machen. Darauf
kannst du natürlich wieder deine eigene Anti-Cheat-AI trainieren, was dann im Endeffekt darauf
rausläuft, dass Cheat-AI versus Anti-Cheat-AI am Start ist. Und das wird noch witzig, aber
direkt nachweisen kannst du es nicht. Ich muss mal kurz die Musik wieder ausmachen.
In Rainbow Six, was? In Rainbow Six werden mittlerweile Spieler wegen einer zu hohen
Headshotrate gebannt, ob sie cheaten oder nicht. Ja, das ist leider die Früchte, die das Ganze
so trägt. Sobald du den Kram nicht mehr direkt nachweisen kannst, wird es halt immer mehr
false positives geben. Also, du wirst halt immer mehr Leute bannen, weil sie halt eine
zu gute Statistik haben. Deswegen ist das, das ist ein echt schwieriges Gebiet und
ich glaube aber, dass das die nächsten Jahre über besser wird. Ich glaube, dass umso besser
das trainiert wird, umso mehr Entwicklung da reinfließt, umso besser wird das Ganze,
aber es wird nie perfekt werden. Ich meine am besten ist halt, wenn du den Cheat direkt
nachweisen kannst, aber das wird bei sowas halt nicht funktionieren.
Einfach die Cheat-AI anhand von Pro-Playern trainieren, um legit zu wirken. So einfach
ist das nicht. So einfach ist das nicht. Du kannst jetzt so eine Cheat-AI nicht programmieren
zu spielen wie ein Pro-Player. Du kannst sie vielleicht trainieren, die Geschwindigkeit
im Aim oder in irgendeiner Art und Weise von einem Pro-Player nachzuahmen, aber ein Pro-Player
hat ja noch andere Sachen. Also, was er denkt während dem Game. Also, das so zu trainieren
wird schwierig. Das siehst du zum Beispiel auch daran. Es gibt ja mittlerweile League
of Legend-Bots, wo auch sogar Pro-Gamer sagen, dass es saumäßig schwierig ist, dagegen
zu spielen und fast nicht mehr möglich ist zu gewinnen, aber die AI spielt halt null
wie andere Pro-Player. Die spielt komplett anders und jeder Pro kann dir quasi sagen,
das ist eine AI, die da spielt und sie können trotzdem nicht dagegen gewinnen.
Nein, ich meine nicht Skript. Ich meine nicht Skript. Es gab mal so einen Versuch, dass
man wirklich, ich glaube, ich weiß nicht, ob es von Google war. Es gab wirklich einen
LOL-AI-Bot im größeren Stil. Es kann auch sein, dass es in Dota war, wo man wirklich
trainiert hat, den Bot spielen zu lassen. Jetzt nicht ein Spiel mit einem Spieler zu
unterstützen, mit irgendwelchen Auto-Bytes oder was auch immer, sondern dass es wirklich
autonom spielt mit dem, was ihm das Spiel liefert. Eine Starcraft-AI, die gab es auch.
Die gab es auch. Da weiß ich aber nicht, wie gut die war. Die hat wahrscheinlich auch
alles geoutet. Nein, aber es gab auch eine LOL-Geschichte. Oder was? Starcraft? Nein,
ich glaube, es war LOL. Und die Pro-Player haben dazu gesagt, dass sie sofort erkannt
haben, was die AI ist und was nicht. Oder Dota. Die Dota-Spieler haben sofort erkannt,
was AI ist und was nicht. Aber sie hatten quasi keine Chance zu gewinnen. Das Ding
ist halt von den Mechanics her absolut perfekt. Ich kenne mich mit LOL und Dota nicht so gut
aus, aber ich weiß, dass es da irgendwelche so High-Level-Mechaniken gibt, so nach dem
Motto, irgendwelche Animationen canceln, links-rechts-steppen, dass dann Boomerang schneller zurückkommt
und solche Dinge. Also da gibt es jede Menge Moves, die du quasi als Pro ausführst, während
du das Spiel normal spielst, dass du aber selbst auf absolutem Pro-Level nicht perfekt
hinkriegst. Also du lässt dann immer mal, triffst du den richtigen Frame fürs Animation-Canceling
nicht oder was auch immer. Und das Problem hast du halt als AI nicht. Der spielt seinen
Character Mechanic-technisch hundertprozentig einfach perfekt. Das ist das, was du als Pro
nicht hinkriegst. Und selbst wenn du vielleicht die Big Brain Moves machen könntest, ist
das Ding dir economy-mäßig schon immer ein Stück dann voraus. Also es ist halt, es ist
halt ein komplett anderes Spiel, als wenn das jetzt irgendein Mensch wäre, der da spielen
würde. Und trotz, also die Pros können dir sofort sagen, ob das eine AI ist oder nicht.
Zumindest stand das damals in dem Artikel drin, dass die Pro gesagt haben, sie können
sofort erkennen, dass das eine AI ist, aber sie konnten halt nicht gewinnen dagegen. Oder
was weiß ich, 1 vor 10 Games oder so. So, guck mal, vid weiter. Es gibt ja auch den,
es gibt ja auch diesen Hack, sorry, das ist schon wieder unabbrechend. Es gibt ja auch
diese Geschichte mit, dass man das am PC probiert. Weiß ich, ob ihr das mitbekommen habt, dass
es ein, Moment, dass es letztens ein Cheatsystem gab für ein PC, der Maus und Tastatur Inputs
simuliert hat. Und die haben das folgendermaßen gemacht, die haben eine PCI Express Karte
eingebaut in den Rechner. PCI Express Karten, Hardware, hat Zugriff auf einen Arbeitsspeicher.
Und das haben die getan, glaube ich, als Netzwerkkarte, obwohl es gar keine Netzwerkkarte
war. Also, die haben eine PCI Express Hardware Karte eingebaut, die Zugriff auf den Arbeitsspeicher
hatte. Die hat quasi den Arbeitsspeicher gescannt, geguckt, wo die wichtigen Daten von den Games
stehen. Das Game hat das nicht gemerkt, weil halt nichts an Software auf dem Rechner läuft,
sondern dass halt eine Hardware Karte als Netzwerkkarte getarnt war. Die hat den RAM
ausgelesen vom Game, hat dann die wichtigen Daten extrahiert, an einen Microcontroller
geschickt und der Microcontroller hat dann Maus und Tastatur bedient. Das war quasi ein
nicht wirklich erkennbarer Cheat auf dem PC, weil du es nicht direkt nachweisen kannst
in Form von, ich erkenne eine Software, ich kenne einen Cheat, der im Hintergrund läuft.
Sowas kannst du nur nachweisen über irgendwelche Statistiken oder sowas. Also du kannst es
nicht mehr direkt nachweisen. Mittlerweile, man könnte natürlich sagen, ja gut, warum
haben die nicht die Hardware im Rechner erkannt? Das ist gar nicht so einfach. Das Ding hat
sich getarnt als Netzwerkkarte. Du kannst jetzt schlecht Leute mit der Netzwerkkarte
im Rechner bannen. Du kannst sagen, ok, Netzwerkkarten mit diesem Hersteller, mit dieser Mac-Adresse
werden gebannt, ok, das kannst du machen, aber dann ändert das der Hersteller einfach.
Also ein Hardware-Hersteller kann ja reinschreiben, was er lustig ist. Das ist kein großartiges
Problem und du kannst jetzt schlecht Leute bannen dafür, dass sie Hardware im PCI-Express-Slot
stecken haben. Das ist das Normalste von der Welt, Hardware im PCI-Express-Slot zu haben.
Die sollte aber nicht direkten Zugriff auf alle Speicher haben. Ich muss dir ehrlich
sagen, ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das unter Windows genau läuft, aber es war wohl möglich,
sonst hätte der ganze Cheat nicht funktioniert. Das auf Hardware-Ebene, wie das Treiber technisch
aussieht, absolut keine Ahnung. Weiß ich nicht.
Mit Stadia wäre das nicht passiert, doch! Klar, mit Stadia, das ist ja grad der Witz
daran, sowas kannst du auf jeder Plattform machen. Also sobald du nur noch den Output
brauchst und den Input hinschickst, ist das komplett plattformunabhängig. Der Cheat
nimmt aktuell, natürlich würde das mit Stadia funktionieren, der Cheat nimmt aktuell das
Output-Signal von der Konsole, errechnet welchen Input er machen muss für einen Headshot und
schickt den Input dahin. Das funktioniert mit der Konsole genauso wie mit Stadia.
Die Chinesen kennen ja gar keinen Spaß mehr, da kommt es ja sogar ein Knast als Cheat-Hersteller.
Das können ja glaube ich gar nicht so einfach. Ich bin mir nicht mal sicher, ob das verboten
ist, ehrlich gesagt. Die greifen nicht in das Spiel ein, die greifen nicht irgendwie
in Rechte von Activision ein, ich kann mir nicht stellen, dass das verboten ist. Ich
wüsste nicht gegen, ich meine keine Rechtsberatung, blablabla, ich hab mir da nicht vorgebildet,
was das angeht, aber ich wüsste nicht, gegen was das verstoßen sollte, wenn du den Output
abgreifst, von einem externen System verarbeiten lässt und dann über den normalen Input wieder
Sachen an die Konsole legst. Es ist fragwürdig, ob das Herstellen solcher Cheats wirklich
illegal ist. Was du sagen könntest, ist natürlich, das Benutzen dieser Cheats ist insofern gegen
die Toss und du kannst die Leute bannen, wenn du sie dann merkst, wenn du es dann feststellst.
Das kannst du auf jeden Fall machen können, aber rechtlich belangend, so eine Cheat-Hersteller,
das stelle ich mir äußerst schwierig vor. Naja, ist das nicht
irgendwie Manipulation der anderen? Schade, doch, aber das ist strafrechtlich eigentlich
kein Ding. Also sag mal so, wenn du jetzt, ich muss jetzt mal irgendwie einen blöden
Vergleich ausdenken, wenn du jetzt Fußball spielst und deine Schuhe tunst, dann verstößt
du vielleicht gegen die Regeln von deinem Verein oder der Liga, in der du spielst, aber
die Fans werden dich nicht dafür verklagen können. Die können dich bannen, die können
dich bannen, dass du nie wieder spielen kannst, wenn sie dich erwischen, ja. Das ist das
gleiche, was Activision auch machen kann. Activision kann dich bannen, wenn sie dich
erwischen und sagen, du darfst dieses Spiel auf diesem Account nie wieder spielen, das
ist okay. Aber die können dich nicht verklagen in Form von, keine Ahnung, ich kriege jetzt
von dir 5.000 Euro. Er könnte es probieren, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es klappt. Sellout,
exzellent Sellout, next. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.ре.0.
Rezaktivision.arna match. Tja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ha. Ja. Ja. Ja.
ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Es ist nicht ein Battle Royale. Wir werden auch über die geschlossenen Technik-Tests und Betas von 2042 in EA Play live informieren.
Ja, da bin ich mal gespannt. Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, da darf ich mitmachen beim Closed-Technical-Test.
Sie werden ein neues Projekt aufbauen, nachdem ihre Arbeit auf Battlefield 2042 beendet wurde.
Sie haben seit 2013 als DICE LA auf der Battlefield-Franchise gearbeitet.
Letztes Jahr hat EA den Founder von Respawn, Vince Sampella, in der Studie in Bezug.
In seiner Richtung werden sie von der Battlefield-Franchise entfernt.
Die Rebrandung zum Ripple-Effekt ist ein Teil dieses Prozesses.
Das Mittelsch
Sie haben es jetzt eigentlich geschafft, dass man seine Mitspieler wieder sieht.
Es wird auf der 15.
Es wird ein neues Zombies-Map für Cold War genannt, Mauer des Totem.
Es sieht aus wie ein klassisches Zombies-Map und bringt viele neue Mechaniken in den Mix.
Es wird die Mule-Kick-Perke, einen Roboter-Kompanion, neue Waffen und mehr genannt.
Als für Warzone klingt es so, als würde das Mittelschneidende-Update
einige größere Balance-Changes zum Battle Royale bringen.
Die Saison 4 wurde mit schwebenden Balance-Changes eröffnet, die einen großen Impact auf die Meta des Spiels hatten.
Der Entwickler sagte, dass ein zweiter größeres Update in der Arbeit war, um die Anzahl der Average zu erhöhen.
Gut, Ravensoft hat jetzt ja sich nicht mit Ruhm beklickert die letzten Monate über.
...TTK of all weapons. These two updates combined should result in a much more consistent experience for all players.
Warzone has also been trending towards faster and faster killing weapons with every seasonal update.
Assuming the mid-season update brings those TTK-Changes, it'll be a return to form for the Battle Royale.
Modern military FPS World War 3 is finally getting...
What? Das gibt's noch?
...an update after nearly a year of radio silence.
The developers announced a partnership with My.Games last year to secure more funding and resources for development.
It also means the game will transition to a free-to-play title, but a whole year later nothing has materialized.
The game's official social media account is teasing an update in four days, and before they had gone...
Also...
Die haben es so mega verkackt.
Das Game, das kam, das haben die angekündigt vor, keine Ahnung, fünf Jahren oder so.
Ich hab mir sogar auch mal damals Early Access mal was für angucken wollte.
Das kam zu einer Zeit, wo die Leute richtig, wie sagt man so, gelechtzt haben nach einem modernen Combat Battlefield.
Und da haben die das angekündigt und haben gesagt, sie machen sowas in der Richtung.
Was natürlich viele Battlefield-Fans gefreut hatten, gesagt haben, cool,
es muss ja nicht unbedingt ein Battlefield von DICE sein, es kann ja auch ein Battlefield von einem anderen Hersteller sein.
Und jetzt haben die einfach fünf Jahre lang nichts gemacht.
Und jetzt, in dem Jahr, wo Battlefield 2042 rauskommt, jetzt wollen sie ein Update bringen?
Die haben die Zeit einfach komplett verschlafen, das kannst du jetzt echt nicht in den Ernst sein.
Nein, nein, RIP, vorbei.
Genau, ja, vorbei, es ist vorbei.
Vorbei, verstehe, also, keine Ahnung.
Am Ende ist es besser als Battlefield, hey, das kann sogar sein, aber trotzdem, es ist ja nicht immer gesagt, dass die besseren Sachen sich durchsetzen.
Ich finde das, ich finde das by the way, super, dass die an irgendwelche, ich weiß nicht, was sie donatet haben, an irgendwelche Tierschutzgeschichten donatet haben.
Aber man muss halt mal ehrlich sagen, 10K, das bezahlen die aus der Portokasse oder nicht mal, das ist noch nicht mal die Portokasse, 10K ist so,
das ist das, was die wahrscheinlich zufällig auf dem Gang finden im Management-Stock oben, Stockwerk.
Ja, das stimmt, das stimmt, Playerbase, Primordial Nightmare, Playerbase ist echt wichtig bei Multiplayer-Spielen.
Das ist mit eines der Faktoren schlechthin, ob ein Spiel langfristig erfolgreich ist oder nicht.
Wahrscheinlich haben die mehr Geld dafür bezahlt, Influencern Geld zu geben, dass die Nachricht verbreitet wird, dass sie 10.000 Euro donatet haben als die 10.000 Euro, die sie donatet haben.
Wahrscheinlich, das wäre so ein richtig typischer Stonks-Move, man donatet 10.000 Euro und gibt dann 100.000 Euro aus, um zu verbreiten, dass man 10.000 Euro donatet hat.
Das wäre ein typischer BWL-Stonks-Move, kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Florian290, danke für den Sub.
Die interessiert mich jetzt nicht so.
Ist jetzt nicht so meine Serie.
Wofür steht eigentlich Stonks für Aktien? Stocks.
Ja, das war doch schon ein Set-Out eingebaut.
Was?
Moment, es gibt jetzt 10 Jahre später einen Witcher 3 DLC?
Okay, okay, es bekommt kein eigenes Story-DLC, es bekommt ein paar extra Items, das heißt im Endeffekt, keine Ahnung, zwei Tage Entwicklungsaufwand oder sowas.
Soll. Wie? Wie billig? Wie billig? Ich dachte, es gibt neue Story, nein, nein, nein, nein, gibt's nicht.
Ich würde den Addon raushauen mit neuer Story, den würde ich sofort kaufen, aber was juckt mich, was juckt mich Items aus der Serie? Ich mein, uninteressanter kann es ja kaum sein.
Okay, die haben irgendwas gebraucht, um noch ein bisschen Geld zu machen, verstehe ich. Verstehe ich, nachdem Cyberpunk ja nicht so gut angekommen ist, muss ich noch ein bisschen Geld mit Witcher machen, ist ja logisch.
Weil die haben mit Cyberpunk auch krass viel Kohle gemacht durch die ganzen Pre-Orders. Er meint eh, dass es kostenlos für bestehende Spieler ist, ja gut, aber wenn du es für die Next-Gen-Konsole kaufst, dann musst du dir das Spiel auf jeden Fall nochmal neu kaufen. Das ist der Anreiz, dass die Leute sich das auf der Next-Gen-Konsole kaufen.
Guck dir Aktien an, okay, okay, okay. Kurs, gucken wir mal. Na ja.
Das ist ja für das Geld, was sie zur Verfügung haben, das erste Mal nicht so. Also die haben ja das Geld von Cyberpunk trotzdem bekommen. Scheiß drauf, ob ihr Aktienkurs runtergeht oder nicht.
Da trifft die doch erstmal gar nicht.
Ich warte schon auf die nächsten Reddits. Wenn das jetzt noch weiterfällt, dann kommt demnächst WallStreetBets an. Was macht CD Projekt RedStick? Kommt da irgendwas?
So, was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an? EA Activision war gestern. Dieser Konzernbewegte, das wird wahrscheinlich 10 Cent, was sonst? Das müssen wir uns nicht angucken.
China-Chinesen-Gramm. Simon Desue exposed auch noch. Wisst ihr Leute, Simon Desue? Ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, warum ich das Video aufgemacht habe, aber ist das nicht der Simplicissimus Typ? Oder einer von den beiden?
Oder bringe ich das jetzt durcheinander? Ist das nicht der gleiche Typ? Ach doch, doch, doch.
Also Simon Desue ist halt auch so einer, wo ich keine Ahnung habe, warum die Leute überhaupt, also erstens verstehe ich nicht, warum die Leute das jemals gefeiert haben. Ich fand das persönlich schon immer mega unlustig, aber okay. Aber, dass man dem Kerl vertraut, irgendwas, das verstehe ich nicht.
Also ich persönlich finde den Typ mega unsympathisch. Das ist so, Simon Desue ist der Typ, der früher in der Klasse immer einen dummen Spruch machen musste, egal wie unpassend es war, weil es eben so sein Ruf war, lustig, funny zu sein. Da musste zu allem einen dummen Spruch machen. So jemand ist das.
Quasi selbst wenn jemand erzählt hat, seine Oma ist gestorben, muss dann einen dummen Spruch machen. So schätze ich den Kerl ein. Gut, keine Ahnung, ob es wirklich stimmt, aber zumindest ist mir der Typ mega unsympathisch. Gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal. Ich will jetzt wissen, wie der Ex paust wird.
Doch, das ist er doch. Alter, wenn ich diese gestellten Reichtumsbilder schon immer sehe, da kann ich auch mit Carl auf den Mount Everest, da brauch ich nicht Simon Desue.
Simon hat jetzt einen neuen, ekelhaften, mutmaßlichen Scam. Den haben wir uns mal etwas genauer angeguckt und etwas dazu recherchiert.
Spoiler, seine Masche stammt aus den USA, hat zig Menschen in den Ruin getrieben, ist aufgebaut auf dem Standard-Baukasten der dubiosen Online-Coaches.
Ach Gott, nein, nicht noch mehr. Ok, Ok, Coaching, Coaching, Online-Coaching, so in a nutshell. Als erstes musst du den Leuten erzählen, Leute, ihr braucht das richtige Mindset, ihr müsst das Gewinner-Mindset haben.
Nur mit dem richtigen Gewinner-Mindset könnt ihr reich werden. Ihr müsst richtig, wie sagt er, ihr müsst hustlen Leute, ihr müsst richtig ran, ihr müsst richtig reinklopfen.
Das Gewinner-Mindset, ihr dürft nicht anscheiden, das Gewinner-Mindset. Und dann, und dann müsst ihr natürlich meine Produkte verkaufen. So.
Ihr braucht das richtig krasse Gewinner-Mindset und ihr müsst meine Produkte verkaufen. Dann werdet ihr rein. Das ist immer exakt die gleiche scheiß Masche.
Dass das da überhaupt noch, das ist ja noch nicht einmal was. Warte mal, Alter, ich muss was trinken. ETF. Alter, normal bin ich jetzt Corona geimpft.
Okay, alles gut, alles, so, weiter im Text. Also, es ist ja noch nicht mal, dass diese ganze, diese ganze Masche hier mit ich mache euch reich, das ist garantiert so was, werde ich mit euch, wenn ich das hier schon sehe.
Das ist ja gar nicht so, als ist diese Masche neu. Diese Masche gibt es quasi schon ewig online und noch viel, viel länger offline.
Dass man den Leuten für viel Geld quasi irgendwelche, soll man sagen, irgendwelche Träume verkaufen will oder ihnen bei irgendwas angeblich hilft.
Sei es reich werden, sei es den Traumpartner finden, was auch immer. Und diese Masche gibt es ja schon tausende Jahre im Endeffekt. Ich sage das aus eigener Erfahrung.
Ich habe sowas noch nie gemacht, aber mein Vater hat sowas gemacht. Mein Vater hatte eine Scam-Firma früher, die nicht zwar sowas gemacht hat, aber ähnliche Sachen gemacht hat.
Also ich habe mitbekommen, was da, was da so abläuft. Das heißt, das ist nicht, das ist nicht neu. Das hat er schon vor 40 Jahren gemacht, ohne Internet und alles.
Dass diese Masche ist nicht neu. So, okay, gucken wir uns das jetzt mal an.
Also wer sich jetzt fragt, was der, ich erzähle es jetzt mal ganz kurz zu erklären, was der gemacht hat, der hatte eine Partnervermittlung, hatte aber nie vor, Partner zu vermitteln.
Der hat quasi irgendwelchen älteren Damen, ich sage mal Omas, erzählt zum Beispiel bei uns, bei mir findet ihr euren Traumpartner, der perfekt zu euch passt und hat mit ihnen einen monatlichen Vertrag ausgemacht.
Die haben krasse Kohle abgedrückt für die damalige Zeit, die Omas. Und anstatt den Partner zu vermitteln, hat er sich drei, vier Herren in ein bisschen groberen im Alter, die halt auch nett ausgesehen haben und gut reden konnten,
hat er bezahlt, dass die für ihn zu den Omas gegangen sind und denen quasi schöne Augen gemacht haben.
Und daraufhin haben natürlich die Omas immer schön weiter Monatsgebühren bezahlt, weil ja so viele nette Herren bei ihnen Interesse haben und vorbeikommen.
Also diese Masche, diese Scam-Masche ist uralt.
Das ging dann übrigens auch irgendwann in die Hose, weil sie ihn erwischt haben, aber Scamas.
Online-Coaches und Future-Digital-Millionärs und richtet sich ganz gezielt auf Menschen.
Wenn ich die schleimigen Leute, wenn ich die ganzen Leute schon sehe wieder.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nicht im Knast, nicht im Knast. Wobei, okay, ich, Leute, ich, ich, ich bin ehrlich, er war nicht im Knast und nicht dafür.
Er war nur in Untersuchungshaft, aber nicht dafür. Dafür, sie haben ihn versucht, sie haben ihn versucht zu verklagen dafür.
Und der Richter muss wohl eins zu eins gesagt haben, also gut, ich kenne das nur von dem, was er so erzählt hat.
Der Richter muss wohl wirklich gesagt haben zu so einer Zeugin, Frau, die damals da Kunde war, muss wohl wirklich gesagt haben,
Frau, ich sage jetzt mal Frau Meier, keine Ahnung, wie die ist, Frau Meier, warum haben Sie denn sowas unterschrieben?
Also das muss wohl so ein offensichtlicher Scam-Vertrag gewesen sein.
Es ist nicht rechtlich, also nicht Scam, strafbar Scam, aber offensichtlich sehr einseitig.
Und der muss sich fragen, Frau Meier, warum haben Sie sowas denn unterschrieben?
Die haben ihn erfragt, also der hat, der hat krass Leute gescampt, aber die haben ihn freigesprochen.
Das war rechtlich nichts zu machen. Da wahrscheinlich auch nicht, ja.
Aber ich will halt sagen, so Scam-Geschichten sind schon so alt wie die Menschheit.
Bevor es losgeht, ganz kurz zum Sponsor des heutigen Videos.
Das ist mal wieder NordVPN.
VPNs sind nützlich, wenn man virtuell den eigenen Standort ändern will.
So kann man ziemlich unterschiedliche Angebote.
In den USA gibt es ganz andere Filme, das hat zum Beispiel jemanden von euch interessiert.
NordVPN ist auch super schnell, ihr dürftet also auch...
Richtig schnell.
...Sowohl für iOS.
Wenn euch NordVPN nicht gefällt, gibt NordVPN.
Ja, auf jetzt.
Erinnert euch an Abad auf einen Zwei-Jahres-Plan.
Ihr alle erinnert euch an Simons Klassiker, wie englische YouTube-Videos eins zu eins übersetzen.
Ehrlich gesagt, nein, daran erinnere ich mich nicht, weil ich das nie geguckt habe.
Weil ich den Kerl von Anfang an mega unsympathisch fand.
Das wird mir jedes Mal bis zum Rest meines Lebens eine Gänsehaut den Rücken runterjagen.
Hi, I'm Chris Brown.
Asshole!
Oder bei einer Mini-Verfolgungsjagd dabei sein.
Oder auch einem Jetski mieten.
Oder sich vor einem Eintages Auto rental stellen und so tun, als würde man es besitzen.
Oder billige Scheißzahnpflegen bewerben.
Oder in Dubai leben, weil man da ja so frei ist.
Ach stimmt!
Das ist ja einer von den Dubai Influencer...
Wie nennt man das?
Keine Ahnung.
Gruppe.
Was gibt's denn?
Es gibt die Madeira Influencer und es gibt die Dubai Influencer.
Gibt's noch was?
Hab ich noch was vergessen?
Haben wir noch ein paar?
Warum geht eigentlich keiner in die Schweiz?
Zu teuer, zu teuer.
Zu, zu, äh, auch zu viel Steuern.
LA Influencer, ah, gibt's die auch noch?
Und jenen kleinen Scam durchziehen.
Man merkt schon, es wurde über die Jahre immer weniger lustig.
Und einfach immer krimineller und hinterhältiger und ekelhafter.
Ja gut, er muss halt sehen, dass er aus seiner, ähm, schwindenden, keine Ahnung, Fanbase,
die ihm da noch traut, das Maximale an Kohle rausholt, ne?
Hatte am Freitag ein Vorstellungsgespräch zum Fachinformatiker.
Interessiert es dich vielleicht, welche Fragen sie gestellt haben?
Ja, ja, können wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Ich guck mir jetzt das Video an.
Ja, jetzt können wir uns eine gute Idee...
Interessiert mich, ja.
Ja, ich kenn auch einen, der gerne noch mehr verdienen würde.
Ich mach's ganz kurz, er verspricht, dass man über FBA, das ist Fulfillment by Amazon,
richtig heftig rein...
Fulfillment by, äh, ähm, das ist Marketplace, oder?
Das ist ganz normales Amazon Marketplace, oder?
Seh ich das jetzt falsch?
Du verkaufst deine Sachen über Amazon und, ähm, du machst halt, du machst halt Fulfillment,
also sprich Versand und, du machst halt die Abwicklung über Amazon.
Reich werden kann, 5.000 Euro die Woche, 10.000 Euro die Woche...
Also du schickst, du schickst deine Sachen quasi an Amazon, an irgendein Amazon Logistikzentrum,
lässt es da lagern und Amazon verschickt es dann, wenn es einer kauft.
Geld verdienen.
Und was Fulfillment by Amazon eigentlich ist...
Damit kann man, damit kann man, damit wusste ich gar nicht, dass man damit angeblich krass Geld machen kann.
...das Amazon dir anbietet, okay, wenn du ein Produkt hast, schick es einfach in unsere Lagerhäuser,
wir verkaufen das für dich auf unserer Plattform, also beziehungsweise wir schicken es halt raus,
wir holen es zurück, wir machen Returns, Kundenservice und halt alles für eine Commission...
Na Moment, Moment, Moment, du schickst das palettenweise an Amazon und die machen den Rest,
so einfach ist es ja nicht, denn Scheiß muss ja jemand erstmal kaufen.
Du musst den Kram einkaufen und du musst, du musst dafür sorgen, dass die Leute den Kram verkaufen
und dann musst du auch irgendwie Gewinn mitmachen.
Einige smarte Leute haben mal gedacht, oha, was, wenn wir einfach super billige China-Produkte nehmen, so Handy-Cases...
China-Chinesen-Kram, beste Idee.
High-Quality-Produkte kommen immer gut an.
...Kram verkaufen, so, oder ist auch was für Small Businesses, et cetera, et cetera.
Und dafür bietet Simon jetzt ein krasses Coaching an, weil er behauptet, dass er damit auch unfassbar...
Um alles in der Welt braucht man da Coaching....viel Geld verdient, er ist einfach der FBA-Gott.
Dafür hat er eine super billige Clickfunnels-Page erstellt, deswegen sehen die übrigens alle mal gleich aus,
weil es dafür so einen Service quasi gibt, clickfunnels.com.
Er hat bei seiner geilen Clickfunnels-Seite nicht mal den Infotext der Webseite geändert.
Da steht tatsächlich No-Cost-Training vor, in eckigen Klammern Market, weil man da halt dann einfügen soll...
Ja gut, jetzt kann sie nicht erwarten, dass Simon Desue irgendein krasser Webdesigner ist.
...No-Cost-Training macht, also der hat das Template nicht mal vernünftig angepasst, das ist so billig.
Man kann nicht sehen, wer die Domain registriert hat.
Und mit seinem geilen Amazon-Dropshipping verdient er bestimmt auch nicht genug, dass er da mal einen Webdesigner bezahlen kann.
Da hat er anonymisiert, schade. Es gibt auf jeden Fall dieses Video, in dem er das alles...
Ich glaube, er müsste mal gecoacht werden, wie man eine Webseite macht.
Das ist super ekelhaft aufgebaut, natürlich.
Letztes Jahr wurden auf Amazon über 386 Milliarden Dollar umgesetzt.
Ja und?
54% davon kommen von Verkäufern, wie ich es bin.
Und er sagt dann so richtig diepe, also wirklich tiefgehende, motivierende Sachen wie...
Und der Knackpunkt einfach machen und tun.
Und auf Instagram hat er noch ein Video veröffentlicht...
Machen und tun?
Boah!
Huge Coaching!
Ein Teilnehmer seines geilen Seminars, der in...
Das ist wie...
Das ist wie wenn in irgendeinem Online-Game, um zu gewinnen, dich jemand coacht...
Also stell dir mal vor, ihr wolltet gut werden in einem Online-Spiel und lasst euch von einem Pro coachen.
Und der Coach sagt einfach zu euch, einfach nicht sterben.
Einfach nicht sterben und alle Gegner killen.
Das ist ungefähr genauso gehaltvoll wie dieses Coaching.
Hat irgendwie was von KLS-Vibes, ja klar, weil das alles der gleiche Crap ist.
50 Dollar verdient hat.
Dieses Gefühl kann ich nicht in Worte fassen.
Und wie viel hast du seit dem Start verdient?
Die sehen beide wie super vertrauenswürdige Menschen aus, denen man jedes Wort glauben kann.
Vor allem...
Ist das eine Goldkette, eine Silberkette?
Wahrscheinlich auch irgendwie krasser Markenpulli, aber mit sowas kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Alles sehr vertrauenswürdige Leute.
Das ist kein Screenshot.
Moment, was?
4856 US-Dollar.
Im Monat.
Gut, kommt auf die Menge an, die du verkaufst.
Das ist kein Screenshot.
Oder in sieben Tagen.
Es kommt auf die Menge an, die du verkaufst.
Das ist...
Das geht schon.
Es ist halt die Frage, wie viel du verkaufst.
Und die Frage ist ja nicht nur, wie viel du verkaufst.
Die Frage ist ja auch, was bringt dir das im Endeffekt?
Ich meine, du musst den Kram bestellen.
Du musst den Kram eventuell irgendwo zwischenlagern, bevor es zu Amazon, was weiß ich, über welche Ecken du das schickst.
Du musst verkaufen.
Du musst Steuern bezahlen.
Also die Frage ist, was bleibt am Ende übrig?
Ich meine, 5000 Dollar in sieben Tagen ist jetzt sicherlich nicht wenig.
Aber es kommt halt auf die Umstände an.
Es kann sein, dass davon kaum was übrig bleibt.
Aktualisieren.
Ja, das ist wohl kein Screenshot.
Aber leider sind Produktverkäufe der Umsatz der letzten sieben Tage, nicht der Profit.
In einfachen Worten, du kannst zwar 1000 Produkte für 5 Euro verkaufen.
Das ist das, was ich im Prinzip sagen wollte.
Sie fragen, was am Ende rauskommt.
Wenn du aber nur 5 Cent Gewinn pro Stück machst, naja.
Aber es gibt noch mehr Anzeichen, dass das Ganze mit hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit ein saftiger Scam ist.
Das erste ist, dass die amerikanische Federal Trading Machine genau die...
Das ist davon abgesehen, so eine Seite zum Refreshen mit irgendwelchen Zahlen drauf,
kann dir jeder halbwegs kompetente Typ bauen.
Diese Fälle verfolgt, nämlich so Get Rich Schemes von wannabe Amazon Seller.
Und wenn man sich das so durchlässt, dann denkt man, dass die direkt Simon verklagt haben eigentlich.
Get started selling on Amazon and make 5 to 10.000 Dollars in the next 30 days,
even if you've never sold anything online before.
Hört sich ähnlich an, ja.
Das klingt ja fast genau wie das Schema von Simon.
Und das Lustige ist, dass diese Masche super alt ist.
Also diese Klage von der FTC ist von 2018 oder so.
Hier gibt es einen Artikel von The Atlantic Anfang 2019 über diesen Gold Rush auf Amazon FBA macht dich reich
und dass da Leute eben übelst heftig über die Ohren gehauen wurden von diesen krassen Coaches.
Die Leute sind aber auch so blöd.
Die sind aber auch so blöd.
Warum macht man da mit?
Ich kann das nicht verstehen.
Okay, es ist ja, die richten sich ja absichtlich.
Doch, ich kann es verstehen.
Die richten sich ja absichtlich an Pepega Leute, die man einfach übers Ohr hauen kann mit sowas.
2021 überlegt, dass es Zeit wird, dass er das mal in Deutschland probiert, I guess.
I don't know.
Einfach machen und tun.
Die Artikel haben wir euch alle verlinkt und so.
Also falls ihr euch da noch ein bisschen analysieren wollt.
Das ist genauso wie diese Videos, die Karl S. immer macht mit seinen, was weiß ich, 5 Millionen Uhren.
Und dann hat er irgendwie so ein komisches Case mit Uhren drin,
die er danach wahrscheinlich wieder abgibt da, wo er sich ausgeliehen hat.
2018 haben sich bei der FTC 50 Leute beschwert, dass sie da unglaublich viel Geld mit verloren haben,
weil ihnen versprochen wurde, boah, FBA macht dich reich, hol dir irgendein Billo-China-Produkt,
zell das, zell das, zell das, dann machst du deine 5 bis 10.000 Dollar die Woche Quatsch natürlich.
Und 25 von denen haben über 35.000 Dollar verloren.
Gut, man sieht aber schon an einer Sache, dass die Leute auf allen Seiten echt doof sind.
Nämlich dadurch, dass so eine Seite wie Wish.com überhaupt existiert.
Wish ist die Seite für China-Scammer, wo die Leute zu dumm sind, in China selbst zu bestellen.
Also sprich, die einzige Existenzberechtigung von Wish ist,
weil Leute unfähig sind, in China zu bestellen,
weil die Leute nicht in der Lage sind, auf AliExpress zu gehen und sich was zu bestellen.
Genau, Wish heißt, ich kenne AliExpress nicht, ich bin zu dumm, bei AliExpress zu bestellen.
Das ist Wish.
Also Wish ist eigentlich die einzige, also Wish existiert nur,
weil Leute zu dumm sind, bei AliExpress was zu bestellen.
Und den haben über 35.000 Dollar verloren.
Aber Simon Desue bietet auf jeden Fall ein Live-Training an, das ist alles live.
Also da ist man dann im Live-Chat mit ihm und kann sich live angucken,
was er dann sozusagen hat im Chat mit anderen Leuten.
Nur leider hat TJ, ganz liebe Grüße gehen raus, falls du das siehst,
schon demonstriert, dass das angebliche Live-Video natürlich nicht live ist.
Ich frage mich, ob der Chat wenigstens wirklich echte Leute sind oder Bots,
dass es Aktivität faked, obwohl du der einzige Zuschauer bist.
Leute natürlich auch darauf hin, dass es einfach eine prerecordete Masche ist.
Es wird keine Wiederholung geben.
Nein, auf gar keinen Fall.
Das Impressum von simonvideos.com slash live-training führt dann einfach zu
getclients.com und getclients.com.
Es ist ein Learning Portal für Leute mit digital Product Businesses,
also für Coaches, Course Creators und so weiter und so fort.
Vertrauenswürdig hoch 10.
So wie Simon und dann stehen da so Sachen wie...
Diese Bilder, diese Bilder triggern mich auch immer richtig.
Simon und dann stehen da...
Diese Bilder, das ist einfach immer...
Das ist, weil die Leute sind für sowas empfänglich.
Anders kann ich es mir nicht erklären.
Du bildest irgendwelche jungen Leute auf dem Schiff ab
und irgendwie sollen die Leute dann denken,
wenn man bei ihnen mal einen Kurs gemacht hat,
dann geht es so steil aufwärts, dass man in einem halben Jahr
in der Karibik auf einem Boot rumschippert
und automatisch durch Nichtstun Geld verdient.
Allein schon wenn ich solche Bilder sehe, weißt du, es ist Scam.
Also wenn Leute im Internet versprechen, dich reich zu machen
und ihr Impressum verlinkt auf eine Seite,
in der ein Typ dir verspricht, dich mit Kursen...
Weißt du, was mich auch immer so wahnsinnig triggert
bei diesen ganzen Coach-Dingern?
Das sind alles mega junge Leute.
Ich sage nicht, dass es nicht junge Leute gibt,
die erfolgreich sein können, aber das sind meistens so,
keine Ahnung, 23-, 24-, 25-jährige Leute,
die dir dann erzählen sollen,
so baust du dein weltweites Business auf.
Wie will der das denn beurteilen können mit 25?
Selbst wenn es Leute gibt, und die gibt es,
die mit 25 Jahren ein richtig krasses Business haben,
lohnenswert darüber zu berichten nach dem Motto,
ich habe jetzt hier einen weltweiten...
Das machst du dann, keine Ahnung, mit 40 oder so,
dass du sagst, guck mal, so ist es, das ist meine Erfahrung,
aber es wirkt einfach total unglaubwürdig,
wenn das alles irgendwie 25-jährige Speaker sind.
Verlinkt auf eine Seite, in der ein Typ dir verspricht,
dich mit Kursen darüber, wie man Kurse macht...
Und die, die in dem Alter wirklich diese Kohle haben,
was anderes tun, auf solche Dinge zu gehen.
...reich zu machen, reich zu machen, dann weißt du...
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, eine Sache,
die ich nie verstehen werde,
bei solchen Dingern ist, wenn ich wirklich
den ultimativen Trick rausbekomme,
dann muss man sich mal überlegen,
stellen euch mal vor, ihr habt wirklich
den ultimativen Trick rausbekommen,
diese eine Masche, mit der ihr ohne viel zu arbeiten
richtig krass reich werden könntet,
würdet ihr das allen Ernstes für ein Apfel und ein Ei
an jeden auf dieser Welt verkaufen, diese Information?
Im Leben nicht, niemals würde ich das verkaufen.
So dumm kannst du noch nicht sein.
Alleine schon aus diesem Gesichtspunkt sind
diese ganzen Coaching schon immer sehr fragwürdig.
Die tun immer so, als hätten sie die Weisheit
mit Löffeln gefressen und wissen das,
was niemand außer ihnen auf der Welt weiß.
Und dann fragt man sich ja natürlich,
wenn die doch so krass schlau sind,
warum machen sie es nicht einfach, ohne jemand zu erzählen?
Okay, das ist der kurze Rundown von
Simons neuem mutmaßlichen Scam.
Und jetzt vielleicht mal so zum Ernst der Lage
für eine Sekunde. Simon Desue hat so 2 Millionen
Follower auf Instagram. Ja, verstehe, das ist mir
absolut unverständlich, aber okay.
Und bewirbt ganz offensichtlich eine Masche,
also ich sag euch mal ernsthaft, bevor ich
Amazon Drop Tripping mit Simon Desue mache,
dann gehe ich lieber mit Carl auf den Mount Everest.
Und das würde ich auch nicht machen.
Und dann spricht er absichtlich den kleinen Mann an,
den Arbeitnehmer, denjenigen, der sich vielleicht
am einfachsten von solchen Versprechen locken lässt,
weil der oder diejenige vielleicht am wenigsten hat.
Was hast du jetzt vorher gemacht in der Ausbildung?
Wie viel hast du da verdient, wenn ich fragen darf?
Wenn ich fragen darf? Nein!
Stell euch mal vor, der Mensch sagt, nein, darfst du nicht.
Ist ja überhaupt nicht gescriptet.
180 Euro netto.
Du hast jetzt das sozusagen in einer Woche schon mehr verdient.
Ach, das Fünffache.
Simon Desue ist einfach so eine Person...
Oh, meine Güte.
...und Luxus pflegt und versucht, aufrecht zu erhalten
mit gestellten Bildern, mit teuren Autos,
mit prolligen Roomtouren, mit seinem Influencer-Leben in Dubai.
Dazu wurde ja auch schon genug gesagt,
zum Beispiel von Jan Böhmermann.
Und seine Maschen sind dann Dinge, mit denen er ganz gezielt
Menschen mit wenig Geld anvisiert.
Viele werden jetzt denken, so was, Ausbildung abbrechen,
aber lohnt sich auf jeden Fall für Amazon,
dank Simon natürlich.
Natürlich, was sonst?
Oh, das tut ja weh.
Entweder werde ich abgezogen oder nicht.
Aber ich habe vertraut, ich habe vertraut.
Das ist natürlich das krasseste Argument schlechthin.
Die Scammer sagen dir, du sollst den Scammern vertrauen.
Das wirkt aber vertrauenswürdig.
Ohne Scheiß.
Ich würde Geld dafür bezahlen,
wenn ich nicht den Interview mit Simon Desue hätte.
Oh, sorry, du bezahlst zu wenig Geld raus.
Dass da immer noch Leute drauf reinfallen,
ich werde es nicht verstehen.
Das tut weh beim Zuhören.
Ja, ist echt so.
Es schmerzt beim Zuhören.
Was ich daran schade finde,
dass es oftmals die Leute trifft,
die vielleicht schon ein bisschen,
wie nennt man denn Leute,
leichtträubig, gutgläubig,
oder vielleicht gar nicht mal so sehr.
Vielleicht sind das einfach wirklich auch Leute,
die Simon Desue schon seit, keine Ahnung, 2013,
oder der ist ja noch länger als ich auf YouTube,
der ist ja 2009 oder irgendwie so,
seit 2009 auf YouTube folgen
und irgendwie mit ihm da lustige, gute Sachen verbinden,
was auch immer, ja,
und einfach ein bisschen leichtgläubig sind
und denken, so diese Masche,
was ja auch immer gerne erzählt wird,
ist so nach dem Motto, Leute, ich habe schon alles erreicht,
aber jetzt ist es Zeit, dass ich ja meine Community
mal was zurückgebe, jetzt zeige ich euch,
wie ich es gemacht habe.
Das ist ja oftmals die Masche auch,
die dann wirklich glauben,
so nach dem Motto, so ein guter Mensch,
der gibt den Leuten jetzt was zurück
und erzählt ihnen, wie es wirklich geht
und wie dann darauf reinfallen.
Das Bittere ist halt, dass es tatsächlich
die letzten verbliebenen richtigen Fans trifft,
die er hat,
und die verarscht er dann auch noch.
Das ist halt für'n Arsch.
Aber gut, so sind die Leute halt.
Also solche Leute.
Da machst du nix.
Gibt es denn ein Scam-FPS-Business-Programm
mit Herr Endpunkt?
Herr Endpunkt meldet sich
in letzter Zeit leider im Discord nicht mehr.
Ich wollte mit ihm ja ein Video aufnehmen.
Er weiß nicht, ob ich euch das erzählt habe,
er hat sich ja gemeldet im Discord.
Ich habe jetzt auch verraten,
dass er Niklas heißt,
das hat er mir erlaubt.
Und ich wollte mit ihm eigentlich
ein Video aufnehmen,
aber irgendwie ist er in letzter Zeit
nicht mehr am Start.
Aber gut, dann...
Dann machen wir das,
wenn er wieder da ist.
So.
Letzte Chance,
YouTube uns was Gutes vorzuschlagen,
sonst gucken wir mal, was haben wir da?
Top Concerns Battlefield 2042
Tja, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
Redis in 100 Sekunden.
Redis kann man in 5 Sekunden
eigentlich beschreiben.
Es ist RAM
mit einer Query-Language.
Es ist dein RAM,
auf dem man
strukturierter zugreifen kann.
Fertig.
RAM, auf dem man
organisierter zugreifen kann.
Oh, wäre gut.
Schwierig zu beschreiben jetzt.
Zumindest RAM.
RAM.
In Memory.
Redis kannst du glaube ich auch
auf Persistent machen, auf SSD,
aber das muss, dass es schnell ist,
dass sich das lohnt, muss das in RAM.
Reddit ist RAM as a Service, genau, genau.
RAM as a Service
ist Redis. So kann man das gut beschreiben.
So, was haben wir sonst noch hier? 10 Gigabit
auf einem Raspberry Pi. Na gut, mit PC,
Express, ist das geil. Ach,
guter Switch, Leute, guter Switch.
Ach, Bewerbungsfragen, stimmt, Bewerbungsfragen.
Ja, ihr habt recht.
Also, zeig mal her.
Wo hat es denn
...
oder das das wäre mir auch zu fies leute was berechnen zu lassen und was
kann man damit alles ein einstellen und als letztes welche games ich zocke der eine hatte mich
exzellent gut und was hast du ihnen geantwortet wofür ist ein router zuständig
Ich meine noobs würden antworten um zu routen das ist aber nicht das womit du punkten kannst bei
Bei vorstellungsgesprächen oder um zu um zu um zu routen für routing ist der router zuständig der router
Die einfachste antwort ist natürlich ein router ist dafür da um zwei unabhängige netze miteinander zu verbinden
dass zwei dass zwei unabhängige netze miteinander reden können von einem netz ins andere netz zu routen
für welche stelle war stimmt als was hast du dich beworben es wäre vielleicht interessant zu wissen
fachinformatiker und dann welcher moment nur dass ich das richtig jetzt verstehe nur dass ich das
jetzt richtig verstehe du möchtest dass ich auf dein video reakte ne heute nicht
ich habe festgestellt es wäre ein router ohne modems hergestellt aber irgendwie fast keine modems
ohne router mehr ja ja ja das das stimmt allerdings nur im heimbereich im business
bereich gibt es das alles sehr wohl ja ok frage was macht dns ist eigentlich auch standard
wenn man da sagt namensauflösung domain zu ip das ist man schon sicher was ist ein gateway naja
der gateway ist in der regel das interface vom router was man aus an seinem endgerät einstellt damit
man ein anderes netz kommt über den router das hängt da stark damit zusammen subnet maske kommt
da noch und was man damit alles einstellen und jetzt ja das finde ich aber cool dass sie dich
fragen welche spiele du spielst da sieht man dass mittlerweile dort auch leute sitzen die für die
spiele nicht das teufels zeug ist ja finde ich gut du hast das rezept einfach erbendes geld ja
das kann man machen easy doch doch das ist glaube ich der gleiche typ ja es ist nicht
mal ganz so ganz so kaputt die standard apps aber wirklich wirklich überzeugt hat es mich
immer noch nicht das ist ja eins vor wundert mich dass noch niemanden koin gemacht hat der
auf ram gemeint wird doch doch gibt schon so gut wie jedes mein im program
als was hast du dich beworben da kam keine netzwerk das hängt immer ganz entscheidend
davon ab wer da sitzt in so einem vorstellungsgespräch also bei uns ist es leider leider muss ich sagen
bei uns ist es leider so dass im vorstellungsgespräch fachinformatik systemintegration da sitzt der
ausbildungsleiter für alle azubis also sprich der hat von technik und tun und blasen keine ahnung
und irgendwie einen personalmensch das heißt niemand der wirklich ahnung von technik hat
sitzt bei uns in dem fisi vorstellungs vorstellungsbewerbungsgespräch das heißt
kannst du komplett klicken das heißt selbst mit technik fragen kommst du da nicht weiter du
kommst bei uns du wirst bei uns alles lustigerweise echt so du wirst bei uns als fisi eher eingestellt
wenn du einen ordentlichen anzug an hast als wenn du technische ahnung hast ja sind aber selber
dran schuld sind selber daran schuld wenn sie nicht gute leute kriegen mit solchen solchen sachen ich
was ich wurde auf eure ich wurde auf einer bewerbung ob ich auch in games raide da finde ich
es eine gute frage das finde ich ist eine gute frage ohne scheiß wenn mir jemand erzählt der
ist mmo progression raider weiß ich der kann auf jeden fall gut mit anderen leuten an was
arbeiten um ein gemeinsames ziel zu erreichen progression ich habe es doch schon in meinem
homeoffice video gesagt mmo progression raider ist die eigentliche homeoffice master race wenn
du wenn du dir sicher sein kannst dass einer gut im homeoffice arbeiten kann und auch gut
zusammenarbeiten kann dann sind es mmo progression raider die wissen wie man online kommuniziert
die wissen wie man mit anderen online zusammenarbeitet so dass was gescheites rauskommt
wie steht so zu winfo was wirtschaft informatik leuten mir ist eigentlich egal was jemand
studiert hat gemacht hat oder sonst wie wenn er seine aufgabe ordentlich erfüllt die er hat
habe ich damit keine schmerzen natürlich was immer leute die kein plan haben wir hatten auch
mal einen der hat erzählt er hat fortgeschrittene vmw erfahrung und wenn man ihn gefragt hat hat
er gesagt er hat mal ein ubuntu vm installiert ja also das ist fragwürdig teilweise was da erzählt
wird aber das beste bewerbungsgespräch aller zeiten das muss ich das muss ich jetzt mal kurz
kurz ein einwerfen also das beste bewerbungsgespräch aller zeiten was ich bei uns mitbekommen habe
war folgendes hat sich jemand bei uns bewerb beworben und der hatte der hatte einen abschluss in
matte der matte matte studiert so mit abschlussarbeit und allem und es ging dann halt so es kam so ein
paar technik fragen und irgendwann ging es dann um seine um seine abschlussarbeit so nach dem
motto ja über was so hat dann einer gefragt von den leuten die dabei gesessen über was war
dann ihre ihre abschlussarbeit und dann hat er dann gesagt so ich denke mir jetzt mal irgendwas
aus ja ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht nicht mehr genau irgendwie so was weiß ich das dritte
theorem von xy oder sowas oder oder was weiß ich irgendwas mathematisches hat er gesagt so und
normalerweise normalerweise wäre jetzt das bewerbungsgespräch an dieser stelle durch gewesen weil alle
die da gesessen hätten hätten gesagt okay drittes theorem von xy ich habe keine ahnung wo von der
typ spricht na ist alles gut der typ hatte nur pech der typ hatte bei uns richtig richtig großes
pech weil in diesem bewerbungsgespräch saß einer der einzige im umkreis von keine ahnung na gut in
frankfurt ist eine uni aber ich sage jetzt einfach mal einer einer der handvoll leute im umkreis von
500 km der wusste was das ist wir haben nämlich bei uns ein auf der arbeit der also das ist ein
riesen riesen mathe fan und der arbeitet quasi nur um geld zu verdienen bei uns und löst ist in
irgend so eine mathe mathe mathe ich habe keine ahnung wie das heißt in so einer mathe vereinigung
und im prinzip der beschäftigt sich in seiner kompletten freizeit mit dem lösen oder mit dem
mit dem mit dem beschäftigen von ungelösten mathematischen problemen also der geht da wirklich
nur arbeiten um bisschen geld zu verdienen und die restliche zeit hat der typ ist er am lösen und
mathematische probleme also das ist wie gesagt einer von handvoll leuten im umkreis von keine
ahnung 500 kilometer der der der wissen hätte wissen können von was der spricht so und dann
kam halt wie es kommen muss das aber interessant wie war dann noch mal das dritte die dritte
theorie ich kenne die zweite kenne ich aber was war da noch mal die dritte und da muss den typ so
übelst aus der fassung gebracht haben dass er gemeint hat so irgendwie da kann ich jetzt nicht
drüber reden mein abschluss mein abschlussprojekt ist geheim da darf ich nichts zu sagen der muss ich
krass raus geredet haben der hat halt gedacht er sagt irgendwas super mathematisches wo eh keine
ahnung von hat und dann ist die sache durch ob der typ überhaupt ein abgeschlossen studio
habe weiß ich bis heute nicht studium auf mich bestellt ja das ist halt echt verkackt
der hat wirklich aber der hat auch echt pech gehabt muss man mal sagen wer kann
er damit rechnen dass ihm das der einzige einer der handvoll leute in deutschland die dazu was
sagen können ausgerechnet bei ihm bewerbungsgespräch mit setzt er
bei mir wollten sie beim gespräch nur wissen was ich gebe ja die story hast du ich habe ich
habe sehr viel leute wie lange stream ich jetzt schon seit drei jahren ich habe die ein oder
andere story ja schon öfters mal erzählen ja mega pech ja das ist eigentlich ist das ein
richtig gutes richtig guter videotitel studium auf mich bestellt
ja das thema hatten wir heute schon aber man weiß ja nicht so genau woran es gelegen hat dass die
dass die ganze infrastruktur down ist oder ist da mittlerweile mehr herausgekommen
solche fragen gehen mir auch immer auf den keks das sind so genannte brain teaser fragen
und das schwappt langsam aus den usa zu unseren bewerbungsgesprächen rüber nur mit dem unterschied
was was ich auch immer nicht verstehe ja also wenn wenn google oder facebook microsoft apple wer
auch immer so komischen fragen stellen und mit den leuten an der tafel binary trees in worten
und so was in der richtung dann ist das google microsoft also das sind quasi firmen mit die die
größten big brains der welt suchen für sich ok aber nur weil das microsoft apple und google
und facebook und netflix und und so was macht das muss das nicht die 015 software klitsche in
frankfurt um die ecke machen aber übrigens dank der hilfe zu meiner bewerbung auf deinem
discord mein ausbildungspass excellent excellent leute ausrufe zeichnen discord wenn ihr big brain
content braucht und ausrufe zeichnen hetzner wenn ihr euren 20 euro hetzner startgutschein
claimen wollt hast du schon mal das heizungsniveau noch nie was hältst du von dort net 6 eine gute
gute Entwicklung ja und und diese diese fragen mit dem wieviel smarties passen in ein smart das
sind genau solche fragen diese art der fragen die jetzt immer mehr rüber schwappt aus den usa
und da geht es im prinzip darum nicht nicht dass du die wirklich beantworten kann sondern dass
man quasi erklärt wie man wie man da rangehen würde vom ansatz her aber ich finde solche fragen
trotzdem bescheuert also richtig richtig hängen geblieben aber gut man kann ja fragen was sie
wollen bei solchen fragen sollen man einfach nur laut genau genau bei uns sind bei azubi
bewerber kaum fragen über fachliche skills bei da gibt es ja ja ist bei uns auch so wie gesagt bei
uns jetzt ja auch keine technikleute dabei bei uns jetzt der oberausbildungsleiter dabei der
keine ahnung von technik hat und irgendwelche personal leute kann man voll vergessen mein ansatz
wäre googeln ernsthaft das würde ich auch antworten so jetzt ja ab und zu bin ich auf twitch aber ich
bin ich bin ja nicht mal ich bin ich bin wuppe los siehst du doch hier mensch stimmt doch gar nicht
fake news alter fake news also mein vorstellungsgespräch für die ausbildung das könnte ich eigentlich mal
das könnte ich eigentlich mal ein video zu machen also mein vorstellungsgespräch für die
ausbildung war total easy wir haben erst ein test gemacht wo sie schon angekündigt haben der test
ist gemein weil es der test ist den sie normalerweise auch leuten geben die sie so einstellen so und ich
konnte davon ein paar sachen beantworten da war zum beispiel auch die frage drin wie geht man aus
wim raus auto exit wim und sowas war da als als frage drin irgendwelche ip tables tabellen und
sonst wie was also ich konnte zu einigen sachen tatsächlich was sagen aber vieles keine ahnung
war halt voll voll verkackt ja wusste ich damals nicht zumindest in dem gespräch danach war war
echt nicht war echt nicht viel ja ich weiß noch dass ich damals als ich das bewerbungsgespräch
also sie haben dann gesagt ok wer möchte anfangen ist ja ok gehe ich immer als erster rein und die
haben ich dann die noch bevor die was sagen konnten habe ich halt so vor mich hin hin gemurmel dass
manche fragen echt fies waren in diesem vorstellungs in diesem in diesem test und haben sie halt
gefragt ja warum da meinte ich also ja gerade bei den ziskosachen da wusste ich teilweise aber
bin ich mal drauf gekommen da hatte man gleich so ein gesprächsthema ansonsten bin ich da raus
wir haben nicht wirklich viel ja großartig geregelt keine ahnung zehn minuten und einen tag später
haben die mich angerufen haben gesagt ja wann können sie unterschreiben ok alles klar
muss jetzt mal wieder zurück auf youtube klar aber die fragen die letzten sagen
guckst du mir noch an aha auch richtig big brain ja ich das ist übrigens auch der grund warum ich
immer ein bisschen bisschen schwierig finde die leute quasi live wie soll ich sagen live
komplexere sachen auszufragen weil es ist einfach so viele leute auch auch leute die wirklich wirklich
gut sind und big brain haben können unter druck nicht kreativ denken das ist aber auch normal
bei der wei deswegen das ist das ist eines der gründe warum ich diese diese diese taktik mit
vorstellungsgesprächen komplexe sachen zu fragen und implementiert zu haben nicht nicht gut finde
weil programmieren und und über probleme nachdenken ist da muss jetzt man muss jetzt ein
bisschen ausholen das ist ein kreativer prozess also wenn du jetzt ein problem lösen willst keine
ahnung du sagst ich möchte was programmieren was mein bildschirm immer ab 17 uhr dimmt oder so
was irgendwie eine einfache einfach eine einfache aufgabe ja da musst du musst du kreativ sein da
musst du überlegen ok wie mache ich das mit der urzeit wie handelt ich keine ahnung man schallt
ja wie mache ich hier wie mache ich jenes das heißt es allein so das überlegen ist ein kreativer
prozess und das programmieren und implementieren und wie mache ich es auch ein kreativer prozess
sondern es gibt zwei sachen die funktionieren einfach nicht zusammen das ist stress gefahr
ernst plus kreativität das geht nicht zusammen und wenn leute unter unter druck sind schon ein
bisschen panik haben oder angespannt sind bei einem vorstellungsgespräch dann kannst du von
ihnen keine kreativen leistungen großartig erwarten dass das geht einfach nicht zusammen
deswegen verstehe ich nicht wie man sich daraus was ableiten will das habe ich noch nie verstanden
und leuchten wir bis heute nicht ein das eine passt mit dem andere nicht zusammen
deswegen finde ich solche solche sachen bescheid ich finde es viel sinnvoller zu sagen hey schick
mal dein githab profil mit ich guck mir das guck mir das an da siehst du nämlich was der
typ macht wenn er wenn er seine ruhe hat und kreativ denken kann aber unter druck kreativ also
druck und kreativ denn das sind so die beißen sich einfach das ist ungefähr so wie wenn du
einem künstler sagst seine maler ja wenn du dem eine pistole an den kopf hältst und sag sagst
jetzt mal mal dein nächstes meisterwerk da kommt sicherlich nichts ordentliches bei rum
das kann ich das kann ich funktionieren wie viel matten haben die abgefragt so gut wie gar nichts
deine mord und worte mutter ist doch schön ich mache immer noch youtube videos falls du nicht
mitgekriegt hast aber halt wenig wenig zu battlefield und call of duty spiel ich ja gar nicht mehr
also ok weiter gibt es wo man hat überhaupt eine möglichkeit ein bewerbungsgespräch nicht
zu nicht zu bestimmt bestimmt so lange es kein so lange es kein nasi schneiderman struktur kram
sein soll ja ich muss euch sagen das ist eines der sachen wo ich mich echt komplett verschätzt
habe ich muss ja auch zugeben können wenn man falsch liegt rainbow 6 habe ich komplett
falsch eingeschätzt ich dachte rainbow 6 ist ein game das kommt raus ich habe die beta gespielt
es kommt raus und nach einem halben Jahr interessiert sich keine sau mehr dafür da lag ich komplett
falsch aber komplett aber nicht bei einem azubi oder bei einem programmierer du schickst
er du schickst er du schickst er eigentlich kein programmierer zu deinem kunde dass der
eben dann einen flowchart malt oder eine implementierungsvorschlag live an der tafel erarbeitet das wäre und
wenn dann soll das irgendjemand anderes machen ich würde es nicht machen so sollte so sollte
es meiner meinung auch meiner meinung nach auch zum größten teil sein man sollte hauptsächlich
gucken dass es einstellungsmäßig und menschlich miteinander passt dass man gut miteinander
arbeiten kann und das ist eigentlich das wichtigste gerade in der heutigen zeit ist ist es doch
viel wichtiger dass man mit den leuten dass man mit den leuten gut im team zusammenarbeiten
kann als dass sie jetzt alles schon wissen weil du kannst gar nicht also es ist saumäßig
schwierig für das spezifische was du jetzt machst jemand zu finden der wirklich ahnung
von hat das ist heute so viele faktoren die da zusammenkommen und unterschiedliche waren
wichtig ist eigentlich dass du jemand aus der ahnung hat und sich schnell einarbeiten
kann und der team mäßig zu deinen restlichen leuten dabei passt das ist meiner meinung
auch das wichtigste der muss so weit ahnung haben dass er sich schnell einarbeiten kann
und so weit ahnung haben dass er weiß nach was er suchen muss dass der jetzt dass du
jetzt den einen in deutschland findest der exakt dein eines problem was du hast lösen
kannst ist doch unrealistisch
nicht wirklich
keine ahnung
entwickler kapitulabschluss kann ich zu sagen ok guck mal weiter also was haben wir hier
am start noch 10 gigabit dieser dieser switch ist übrigens richtig poggers den habe ich
auch hier das ist ein mikrotik ich glaube in cc css oder crs 305 ist das glaube ich
der ist wirklich poggers was hat das bitte schon mit cc na zu tun
ich will eigentlich nur mal den switch switch sehen ob das der richtige ist den ich denke
ja heißt das ist das ich glaube das ist das das ist das css 305 css 305 305 mikrotik
ja ist er doch sag ich doch hier poggers super ein super switch schrägstrich mit bisschen
routing funktion nicht so wahnsinnig viel aber bisschen kannst du mit machen also bandbreiten
mäßig damit jetzt keine zwei abteilungen über verschiedene aber ansonsten ist das
schon in ordnung der ist wirklich gut der ist nicht teuer
kostet glaube ich nur irgendwie ja 100 100 112 euro 115 mit versand 115 euro du bekommst
einen gigabit port und 14 gigabit ports glasfaser eigentlich richtig gut um network dabei der
rest interessiert mich vor dem video ehrlich gesagt jetzt nicht nicht so viel haben wir
haben wir vielleicht noch benchmarks
ja genau das ist nicht mal ein bruchteil nicht mal ein bruchteil von zählern das liegt aber
daran dass die pz express bandbreite schlicht und ergreifend zu zu gering ist
man kann
man braucht überhaupt keine 10 gigabit karte man kann sich einfach eine 2, genau man kann
man kann 2,5 oder eine 5 gigabit karte nehmen das ist dann von der infrastruktur je nachdem
was man hat auch billiger aber es hat eh kaum einen 2,5 g oder 5 g router bei sich daheim
oder switch da ist es tatsächlich 10 g einfacher zu bekommen der große vorteil warum sich das
über kurz oder lang doch durchsetzen wird ist weil du die kabel verwenden kannst die
schon da sind für 10 gigabit brauchst du meistens neue kabel oder wenn du glück hast
es kurz genug ist kannst du 10 g auch mit alten kupferkabel machen aber eher nicht oder
du brauchst glasfaserkabel 2,5 und 5 g kannst du halt über die ganzen alten oder 15 kupferkabel
machen und das ist halt für den heimgebrauch einfacher
rtx 4090 das wird doch im leben nicht stimmen
so also was gucken wir uns den jetzt an ah lockpicking lawyer das muss aus prinzip immer
sein
nee carlocks interessiere mich nicht was haben wir denn sonst noch ok safe safe öffnen
cosy cosy safe also das video ist nur 1,30 lang das heißt wir wissen jetzt schon wird
das öffnen sein jepp lock
ok easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy easy embarrassing
Wenn ihr Fragen oder Kommentare habt, schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Wenn euch das Video gefallen hat und ihr mögt mehr von uns sehen, dann abonniert.
Und wie immer, habt einen schönen Tag. Danke.
Wenn ihr Fragen habt und ihr mögt mehr von uns sehen, dann abonniert.
Wenn ihr Fragen oder Kommentare habt, schreibt sie in die Kommentare.
Okay, er buddelt echt ernsthaft in den Tunnel bei sich unter der Hütte, warum nicht, kann
man machen kann man machen war okay ja in deutschland kann man das nicht machen echt nicht na gut in
deutschland darfst du vieles nicht machen du darfst auch in deutschland nicht einfach einen baum
fällen bei dir auf dem grundstück deswegen darfst du bestimmt auch kein tunnel buddeln
bei dir auf dem grundstück illegale unterkellerung ernsthaft sowas gibt es
bei uns in deutschland ist es schon echt geil du kannst auf deinem eigenen grundstück noch nicht
machen was du willst der wahnsinn nach china oder ami auswander nähe wir könnten es bei uns einfach
mal unseren scheiß zusammen kriegen und den leuten mal ein bisschen mehr freiheit lassen
sowas zu machen auf ihrem eigenen grundstück so also komm wir gucken so eine battlefield an
bisschen dunkel oder der sieht doch gar keine gegner
ja alles da in der ask schon schuldet aber da flippt ja voll aus bei den viel vier
in one shot on gullin peaks to start us out you don't see that very often on battlefield for next
up its prolosco with some high skill scout helikopter gameplay dropping in a few only in
battlefield moments along the way on a heli action ist langweil ich will keine heli action sehen
keine keine heli action für infanterie action jawoll jawoll schön c4 eintrocknen die musik im
hintergrund so muss das sein schön alles wegspringen warum die gegner hinter ihm nicht
auf ihn schießen ist nicht weiter zu beachten das detail ich frage mich auf welchem server die immer
solche gegner finden
auf der anderen seite du hast permanent eigentlich sowas ich meine es sind ja immer nur ausschnitte
das kann sein dass das rechtliche game auf den sack gekriegt hat ein cooler ausschnitt das ist
in battlefield also du hast mal ein battlefield auch durchaus in der runde wo es nicht so gut
läuft mal so drei vier minuten wo du übelst uns aber meistens sind es auch richtig gute
spieler die immer oben sind ja
so muss das sein
übrigens übrigens richtig nice
dass man also battlefield battlefield 3 und 4 da war ja reken recoil control easy du hast
bei den waffen einfach nur im gewissen intervall schießen muss man manchen sogar lauerfeuer
und leicht nach unten ziehen fertig kein recoil ich finde ich finde ich finde ich finde es mega
langweilig nicht dass man ist nicht dass das nicht gut leute sind aber ich bin heli und
flugzeug clips mega sleeper nicht resident sleeper mega sleeper
battlefield 2042 muss ja im prinzip diese map mal fünf sein von der größe
das mega resident sleeper
er fliegt halt rum und best schiffe ja das ist sicherlich nicht easy vor allem auch
permanent nicht getagelt zu werden oder irgendwie gehe ich finde halt chat clips langweilig
man kommt battlefield 224 er war das oktober november habe ich schon wieder vergessen
das stimmt das stimmt das hast du das hast du das hast du echt selten
millikill mit dem kanatwerfer oder direkt direkt impact kills mit dem kanatwerfer so
rum wo die granate ist ganz knapp an ihm vorbei die epitose pg das dlc map ja
das sind snipe clips die lasse ich mir gefallen
was ist mit dem dude los da oben will er nicht mal auf ihn zurück snipen
oder wagen ab der wagen ab
gut dass sie immer stehen bleiben zwischendurch
das war ein echt nicer headshot das hier das war ein echt nicer headshot
nicht schlecht ich hätte fast gedacht es war ein collateral
eben ah der erste ist nicht gestorben aber nicer clip das war ein cooler clip
ganzen snipers natürlich hat die map immer noch die gleichen bugs meinst du es hätte
irgendjemand gefixt die letzten acht jahre über
er wurde von fußbodenheizung gekillt das erniedrigend von fußbodenheizung
gekillt zu werden wieso wie alt wie alt bist du also ich bin jetzt sie noch nicht
ganz aber fast 37 und wenn ich battlefield spiele dann geht das immer noch
wird immer noch gebashed 49 ok dann weiß ich ich habe noch zehn jahre zeit was zu
auen danach ist vorbei die lege henne jawoll
wisst ihr das verstehe ich manchmal nicht warum liegt der typ da der typ eben hier
warum warum liegt er da der da was was was macht er da das es macht doch überhaupt
keinen sinn da zu liegen was ist seine mission genau was hat er
vor er hat sogar mit mit strenger stream quite a lot can be worth checking out as
wir roll up towards the release of 2042 the first is a highlight from goldmode
railway as he has a pretty big kill streak as he usually does but he hits
five toes in a row here's a few of them as we just look at part of the streak
insane accuracy from one of the best pilots one of the best players in
battlefield 4 man if you make five oh da gut
and his final clip is something epic I've actually been in the heli with him
when he does this little trick on sees a shanghai and I always think we're going
to crash really epic stuff what the fuck okay das ist das ist man nice hilly
hilly flying moving on to a locker clip its eros with a huge m249 back rage it's
about a minute of him just dominating players back rage jawoll zeigt mir die back rage
im battlefield 4 im vergleich zu battlefield 3 ist support mit lmgs
tatsächlich relativ beliebt einfach weil sie nachladen muss und nicht so
pressed wirst und leute so pressen kannst im battlefield vier kannst ja
nur mit der lmg leute so pressen wenn ich noch irgendwie das richtig im kopf
habe
das ist na also sie machen um kilt sind immer nice zu sehen
slightly longer clip für junext in his usual fashion we're gonna be seeing a
clip from dusty as he plays on a map and mode combination that we rarely get to
see on the top plays the scope of omen and it's rush now this map is very
difficult to play best player in my my lieblings meine mit abstand lieblings
war im battlefield 4 acr not much cover you do get a couple of buildings here
and there but in terms of the map undulating and having some good cover on
at least these m-coms you don't really get it so vehicles can have a field day
against you and often you find yourself pinned back if you've got somebody like
dust on your team though who is keen to get onto the objectives and just get as
many kills as possible an aggressive infantry player you're in luck this is a
nice one is he kind of sweeps up the enemy players playing around the
objective just clearing it up for his team
eins muss man sagen was sie immerhin bekommen haben im battlefield ist
richtig geiler sound oder fällt euch in bettel viel an was kacke sound hatte mir
nicht auch wenn die letzten zwei nicht meins waren sound technisch waren die
sicherlich auch extrem gut ist next with a streak on shanghai with the m16 a4
again it's a rush streak wobei ich ja sagen muss battlefield 3 beziehungsweise
am erster bett company 2 bett company 2 mit war tapes beste
laria but at the same time you've also got a lot of players coming from
different angles it's more players on a smaller part of the map as opposed to
conquest where people tend to be spread out a lot more a nice aggressive
infantry play rana to a com rato
dext thanks for watching this episode as a field for top plays gg it's
das habe ich mir auch gerade gedacht für battlefield hat eine ziemlich
niedrige sens ich spiele in bettel field auch absichtlich immer ein bisschen
höher weil ich keinen bock habe hier einmal über schreibt nicht zu kurbeln
für eine halbe drehung
das sind alles die ehemaligen cs pros die quasi erst mal einen kilometer rennen
für eine halbe drehung was war denn eigentlich schlecht an
battlefield 1 kann ich nicht sagen ich habe viel eins nie richtig gespielt hat
mich null angesprochen habe die beta gespielt hat mir nicht gefallen
und zu sagen war nicht mein fall battlefield 5 habe ich ein bisschen
gespielt auch in ordnung aber hat mich auch nicht so gecatcht irgendwie
deswegen ich habe echt große hoffnung battlefield 2042 aber wie gesagt nicht
vorbestellen und am ende kann sich immer noch scheiße spielen es bringt nix wenn
ein spiel aus ganz vielen guten teilen besteht oder aus aus vielen teilen mit
potential besteht wenn die nicht zu einem gesamten guten game zusammen
gefügt werden
und aktuell sieht es halt aus als hätte battlefield 2042 schon viele teile mit
potential aber ob dann ein gutes gesamt game bei rauskommt das müssen sie
erst mal beweisen ich ich ich würde es mir wünschen ja dass
schon wieder ein battlefield habe wo ich bock habe jeden tag den krassen
battlefield crime zu machen in your face
immer noch ei ist nicht so als hätte nicht er auch gute spiele gemacht oder
raus raus published die werden die werden garantiert die haben wir schon
gesehen dass sie die war zone monetisierung geschichte machen mit
season passes und sowas wie viel sollte ein frischer software entwickler der
1,5 jahre als werkstätten der firma gearbeitet verdienen was sagst du
wie gesagt ich kann da nicht wirklich viel zu sagen es kommt ganz entscheidend
darauf an in welche regionen und in welcher branche du bist
ich kann es echt schlecht sagen es gab bei heise erst letztens nur um frage ja
helium meinung habe ich schon gehört über laura aber ich glaube nicht dass
das irgendwie was wird
aber ich habe hunger und zwar ist es 12 bin ich schon an 220
bock ich bock marke mir das mal sessions session kw besser name alle tabs
gebucht macht weil ich glaube ich gehe mir jetzt was zu essen machen und ich
nehme nachher noch ein video auf wie gesagt ich wollte ihnen video aufnehmen
zu diesem zu diesem cheat geschichten was level cap da auch gezeigt hat
völlig ist ein interessantes thema und ihr habt mich eben ihr habt mich auf die
paar ideen gebracht im chat heute für neues video videos einmal einmal dass
ich über mein eigenes vorstellungsgespräch damals zur
ausbildung erzählen könnte könnte da gab es ein bisschen mehr zu erzählen was
ich im stream gemacht habe plus ich fand das ist eigentlich auch ein gutes thema
gewesen so was da was aktuell schief läuft so mit vorstellungsgesprächen so
diese ganze wie viel smarties passen in einen smart und und so was dass ich
viele viele firmen für das nächste nächste google oder facebook halten
obwohl sie irgendeine software klitsche aus aus in einem kaff sind
gucken wir mal die silicon valley habe ich nicht gesehen
ist das nicht so eine comedy serie da habe ich ein paar ausstätte davon
gesehen ist das die ist das die serie wo es
wo es dieses diese diese sagen wir mal in anführungsstrichen berühmte berühmte
szenen gibt wo sich der typ mit seiner freundin drüber streitet ob imax oder
wim
was ist das ok ja da kenne ich nur diesen ausschnitt
so schauen wir mal wer ist ein ordentlicher hosten hier der frasier ist
nicht da der frasier spiel wieder irgendwelche
mobile games da will er eh nicht von mir gehostet werden
ich gehe ich gehe jetzt auf ich gehe was zu essen machen bis denn wir sehen uns
zu